does the black moon howl no not yet see
the boy he was born in a time before
names there weren't enough humans around
to need them back then he was one of a
handful occupying a Coastal Village
using a tongue long since instead they
eked out a simple life hunting Gathering
fishing the only thing on most of their
minds was surviving to see the next
sunrise yes a simple life free of
complications until the hermit appeared
the boy would remember this man for
eternity Haggard and thin skin weathered
by time and pain a man that emaciated
walking with a long gnarled cane that
honestly looked healthier than he did
shouldn't be alive even the boy who had
scarcely seen beyond the bounds of his
village knew that the hermit was
unnatural an aberration an anomaly he
walked into the center of the village
sat down on a large Stone and waited
nobody dared ask his business nor what
the hermit waited for then a few days
later the black moon howled the boys saw
The Village's youngest Hunter freeze one
evening while out on a walk not simply
stand still but freeze then for an
instant he became solid black a coal
statue and as soon as he'd changed he
was gone obliterated not a trace of him
remained such is the power of the black
moon it can make any conscious being
disappear in an instant turn black then
wiped from our plane of existence never
to be seen again its choice of victims
seemed at each instance to be utterly
random but it would come for all who
lived eventually this is known to some
as the howling of the black moon later
that same night the boy found himself
talking to the hermit who asked with
small frantic eyes what he had seen when
the boy told him he let out a deep
rattling sigh the boy curious asked him
if he knew about the nightmare he'd just
witnessed The Hermit looked up he'd been
the first one in the hermit's Millennia
of pursuit that had ever asked in that
moment he knew that he had found his
successor in the hunt for the death of
Ages The Hermit told the boy it went by
many names the great finale The Pale
King but most common of all was the
black moon The Entity existed Beyond the
Veil of our reality a creature of pure
energy though nobody could really be
sure of its true nature The Hermit had
been tracking it learning about it and
trying to destroy it for thousands of
years and yet it only took him four
pathetic minutes to tell the boy
everything he knew the boy knowing still
that something about the hermit was
unnatural asked how he came to be in
this position The Hermit told the boy he
was the counterbalance a kind of Chosen
One dust into face and perhaps even
defeat the black moon someday the
counterbalance receives a number of
truly extraordinary gifts for inheriting
the responsibility
eternal life
eternal youth near physical immortality
but they will be haunted by their
purpose doomed to watch everyone they
love die around them as they continue to
hunt their only true equal and opposite
the black moon itself The Hermit in his
own eyes had failed at its Duty he had
grown weary and now he needed to pass
the duty of counterbalance onto another
that other would be the boy he felt a
sudden and profound change along with
the knowledge that nothing would ever be
the same again he was no longer just the
boy now he was the counterbalance he
watched The Hermit give him a slight
knot of respect and then crumble into
dust before his eyes the boy the
counterbalance looked up at the sky and
saw the Stars twinkling so bright and so
beautiful little did he know his battle
with the black moon would Outlast every
single one of them does the black moon
howl not without blood the boy grew into
a man as his village aged and then died
around him decades passed then centuries
then Millennia tens of thousands of
years watching Humanity develop and grow
around him as he continued his pursuit
of that one elusive foe as science and
diagnostic technology gained ground
absorbing and then evolving beyond all
the old superstitions the counterbalance
gained a better understanding of the
black moon though even then it still
remained essentially a stranger The
Entity was entropic a being of pure
Randomness and Chaos without consistent
form it didn't exist in our universe but
it could exercise its influence here
with so-called obliteration events much
like the horrible fate that befell the
young hunter from the village but that
was only the proverbial tip of the
iceberg the counterbalance tracked and
noted obliteration events they were
exceedingly rare at first something that
occurred once every thousand years or so
like a terrible curse but he couldn't
help but notice a concerning Trend
emerging it started happening once a
century then once a decade he could feel
the terrible future stretching out in
front of him how over their shared
eternity the black moon would gain more
and more ground would there come a day
where it took someone once a year once a
month a week a day an hour a minute a
second he'd spell the end of all
conscious life life a total victory for
the black moon the end of the universe
the death of Ages a complete existential
obliteration he was swept up in a
sobering realization he couldn't win
this fight alone however while his hunt
for the black moon had been largely
fruitless the counterbalance had
discovered many other things along the
way strange creatures objects with
extraordinary powers and events that
couldn't be explained with rational
science perhaps something about these
Oddities
these anomalies would hold the key to
defeating his Timeless enemy and it
hadn't just been these objects entities
and events he'd also discovered some
truly exceptional people on his travels
minds and skills that rivaled even his
own despite his age perhaps they would
be the ones to help him win with the 13
most brilliant and trusted people the
counterbalance ever met he decided to
form a council and from this Council
they forged and directed an organization
dedicated to understanding and
counteracting the strange in all its
forms with the secret hope that their
search Into Darkness would yield the
answer to the black moons downfall he
called it the SCP Foundation they would
secure the anomalous contain it and
protect all of humanity from its
influence the counterbalance also took
on a new title The Fitting of his new
role the administrator and even the
black moon itself was given a moniker in
hopes of robbing it of some of its
frightening power
scp-001 does the black moon howl only at
the blind the year was now 1987. the SCP
Foundation had been operating for over a
century and thanks to their secret
possession of anomalous wisdom and
Technology their own advancement was
thousands of years ahead of the rest of
humanity while there's still wasn't a
silver bullet solution to the black moon
and its deadly howls were becoming all
the more frequent as the decades went on
the foundation did have some irons in
the fire to combat it their ability to
gather Intel on both the entity itself
and its obliteration events had improved
considerably thanks to their new Global
Information Network their top Minds were
also working on a highly classified
device known as the singular conceptual
bunker which may one day come in handy
for combating the extra dimensional
entity directly but the most valuable
piece of information they ever gathered
about the black moon was this it
couldn't howl when it was being watched
the very Act of engaged observation
defend it the problem is How Can You
observe something that doesn't
technically exist inside your own
reality in order to pull this off the
foundation would need to get extremely
creative thankfully Creative Solutions
to strange problems are the foundation
special T Flash Forward to 1993 enter Dr
Moto a brilliant young scientist and
conceptual engineer working for the SCP
Foundation with the administrator's
consultation he started the key project
an arm of the wider project oromace the
umbrella Initiative for using modified
anomalous objects in the battle against
the black moon the goal of the key
project was relatively simple if people
couldn't observe the black moon directly
then the foundation could make proxies
of the black moon that could be observed
almost like a kind of voodoo doll these
new anomalies would only need to satisfy
three criteria the inability to operate
when being observed a hostility to
conscious life and the ability to end
conscious life of their own volition
when not being observed through
conceptual engineering a link
theoretically could be forged between
these objects and the black moon
allowing observation of them to stop the
obliteration events however despite
being a good idea in theory Dr Moto's
efforts were marred with errors and
tragedies one object wasn't deadly
enough simply appearing behind people in
a threatening pose when they weren't
looking another one killed purely
through collateral damage a giant
sculpture of a human head that
immediately attempted to escape by
barging through site-01 the center for
anti-black Moon operations and killing
19 people in the process another one of
Moto's objects a huge black sphere
simply immediately exploded killing 12
people and in the most horrific misstep
of all one of Moto's objects caused a
mass death event in a nearby hotel where
142 people were spontaneously
incinerated when the object a series of
interlocking stalactites and stalagmites
were left unobserved for 0.2 seconds
almost all of Moto's objects were
terminated in the aftermath either being
too useless or too dangerous to keep
around the young scientists felt a deep
shame but forged on he may made one
truly brilliant creation that satisfied
all the criteria a sculpture incapable
of moving while being watched but would
snap the neck of the nearest conscious
entity if it left unobserved for even a
fraction of a second its relatively
minimal killing left it easy to contain
without causing Mass deaths and despite
all the other deaths that had sadly
occurred during the key project Dr Moto
believed that the lives saved in the
long run by stopping the black Moon's
howls would justify the sacrifice the
problem is the key project didn't stop
anything not long after this there was
the first recorded double obliteration
event in Rome where a young tourist
couple had both been obliterated
simultaneously all the deaths in the key
project had been for nothing the black
moon was only getting more powerful the
shame in the guilt was too much for Dr
Moto he left a note in his office
Reading we've been looking at nothing
I'm sorry administrator I failed you sir
MO corpse was later found in the
sculpture's temporary containment
chamber his neck snapped the key project
was in summary shut down and its one
surviving creation transported to site
19 in late 1993 where it was designated
as
SCP-173 another painful failure for the
administrator back to the drawing board
once more does the black moon howl not
while the stars shine Millennia
stretched on almost everyone died except
the administrator thanks to his gift or
perhaps curse as the counterbalance to
the black moon science marched on the
SCP Foundation marched on but all this
progress all this power was nothing
against the incomprehensible influence
of
scp-001 the black moon was howling more
frequently than ever all the way up to
the year 3156 when the foundation
launched the seek project under the
support of project oromastes has more
and more people were wiped out in
frequent obliteration events the
administrator became painfully aware
that perhaps the answers to the black
moon problem wouldn't be found on Earth
using state-of-the-art technology With a
Little Help from the anomalous the SCP
Foundation began work on an autonomous
space-faring vessel that could search
the stars for the key to the black
Moon's destruction it was an
awe-inspiring creation a huge craft
powered by artificial intelligence with
a universal translator cryogenic units
and hundreds of autonomous drones to
perform more targeted searches Zeke was
waved off into the unforgiving depths of
space the administrator could only hope
that it would come back with worthwhile
answers the first of the three notable
planets seek derived on was one
theoretically capable of supporting
human life except for its brutal and
constant blizzards and snowstorms when
Sikh drones were deployed they did
discover signs of civilization based
around sentient spherical creature
teachers but no signs of actual life
remained records and statues found
across the planet seem to indicate that
the black moon was responsible for the
destruction of the planet's civilization
causing so many obliteration events that
the remaining survivors went mad from
the fear and stress leading to mass
death in the ensuing chaos the next
planet was discovered centuries later in
the year 3499 while this planet could
also theoretically support human life it
suffered from frequent volcanic
eruptions that rendered much of its
surface a flaming Mass however there
were still the dormant ruins of a once
Advanced civilization of conscious
beings much like the prior Planet they'd
been driven extinct by Black Moon
obliteration events a century before the
Sikh even arrived unlike the last planet
however it seems that they accepted
their fate and went gently into the
night the planet was now overrun by
billions of armored bat-like creatures
that operated on pure Instinct and thus
were not considered conscious just
enough to be obliterated the final
planet was reached in 3764 and was the
most fruitful of the three discoveries
this planet was hyper Advanced fully
urbanized and covered in sprawling mega
cities with records and Technology over
a thousand years ahead of Earth before
the black moon killed almost all of them
there were a species of humanoid
telepathic fungi and that developed an
awareness of the black Moon's existence
that was on par with that of humanities
they even had their own equivalent of
the SCP Foundation actively working on
countermeasures and most amazingly of
all seek found one surviving member of
the species on the planet cryogenically
frozen The graft was immediately
instructed to collect the Survivor and
return home for interrogation the
administrator Was preparing for what
could be the most important conversation
since he met the hermit all those
thousands of years ago does the black
moon howl only when waning when the
surviving creature codenamed aged was
returned to Earth the administrator was
eager to finally speak with it like the
rest of its now extinct species Sage
spoke through powerful telepathic mind
waves which only the administrator
thanks to his counterbalance abilities
was able to receive at close range
without being harmed incidentally it
wasn't long until the very fact of the
administrator's nature as a
counterbalance came up in the mental
conversation Sage could tell just by
being in his presence they discovered a
number of vital truths over their brief
time communicating that Sage's survival
had been pure luck for starters the
black moon is still very much capable of
obliterating conscious beings in an
unconscious State the administrator also
learned that he was merely the latest in
an extremely long line of
counterbalances across time space and
species though everyone but him had
waved this Duty passed it on Sage had
one question to ask the administrator in
turn what is SCB
the singular conceptual bunker being
worked on and perfected for thousands of
years by now by the foundation's top
scientists and conceptual Engineers the
administrator replied Victory but it
will take a very very long time
specifically so long that he would see
the stars go out around him one by one
shocked saged asked him what good
victory would do him then rather than
say it aloud he replied with a thought
Sage paused and said I see how
Blasphemous of you hopefully it works
after this the administrator proceeded
to the singular conceptual bunker and
entered it leaving instructions for the
foundation to be run by a newly formed
o5 Council in his indefinite absence
thousands of years later in the year
5011 Sage spoke one more time repeating
the words hopefully hopefully before
turning solid black and disappearing the
black moon had claimed one more victim
but billions more had gone in the
interim the administrator had no more
answers to give at least no more answers
that anyone but him would understand he
was inside the singular conceptual
bunker now loaded into a device known as
Tome an experimental Memorial module
meant to pick up and record all the last
messages of every dying civilization
Across the Universe when the time
finally came all he could do was wait
and wait was exactly what we did does
the black moon howl yes yes it does
years pass too many to count it's a time
after names now and Tome sits in the
very center drinking in the end of the
universe the last of all the human
colonies Across the Universe were
obliterated by the Black Moon back in
the year 73-29 so so so so long ago but
some of the final messages of fear panic
and distress still echoed around in the
administ Trader's mind hello is there
anyone here
we require assistance there's it's it's
taking people every day we need help
there's barely anyone left we need help
hello hello cabal zero nine four three
we have abandoned the false flesh we
have abandoned the false flesh the
shepherd's crook broke beneath my knee
Cabo zero nine four three come on zero
nine four three forgive us forgive us
we're going to leave this
so dark outside now it's blotted out the
sun it's I have to go now respond First
Convenience emergency
situation developing require additional
resources my your fault our fault
my fault your fault our fault my fault
your fault remember now rip my brain out
now and a small child the last on Earth
simply asking hello into an indifferent
microphone but the administrator had to
wait as the singular conceptual bunker
became the solitary conceptual Punker he
was the last conscious being in the
universe and still he needed to wait as
the Stars went dark outside only when
there was nothing outside but black was
it finally time for the counterbalances
long game to play off there was nothing
left of our universe the only thing here
was the SCB and the black moon itself
with everything else gone the black moon
only had one conscious being left to
obliterate it opened the door to the
solitary conceptual bunker and stepped
inside this this doesn't make sense how
can the black moon an entity beyond our
Dimension Beyond physical form take a
step good question the same question
incidentally that was going through the
black Moon's mind as it entered the
bunker it didn't look at all how the
entity expected it was like a bar a
counter with rows of bottles behind it a
jukebox playing in the corner a man
stood behind the bar cleaning the
glasses the counterbalance the
administrator he said well there you are
certainly took your time can I pour you
a little something this only served to
increase the black Moon's confusion it
had form here dark smoke compressed into
a vaguely humanoid shape it could speak
it could think none of this may made any
sense the being that had just wiped out
all conscious life and seen the very
death of the universe was truly and
utterly confused the administrator just
seemed to be enjoying himself preparing
for a confrontation hundreds of billions
of years in the making the singular
conceptual bunker or perhaps the
singular containment bunker was a truly
ingenious creation a place of pure ideas
where everything inside was on the same
level here there were no Immortals no
Gods just ideas on the same Level
Playing Field and it was time for the
black Moon's idea to come to an end it
was a trap and the entire universe was
the bait without warning the
administrator pulled up a shotgun from
underneath the table and unleash both
barrels into the black Moon's chest the
creature took the head and fought back
dragging the administrator to the ground
beating him strangling him he could feel
the light fading under the mount
Monster's Relentless assault until he
managed to get his desperate hands on a
glass ashtray he beat the monster over
the head with it until it's gripped
loosened and he was able to slide out
there the killer of the universe was on
the ground before him he grabbed the
monster held it in place and beat it to
death he was Gravely injured by the
battle but the black moon was no more
here in the singular conceptual bunker
he had won the administrator no longer
the counterbalance in the absence of the
black moon hobbled over to the Jukebox
produced a single beautiful coin from
his pocket he pushed the coin into the
slot wheezed a pain breath and said the
thing is this place is only information
there's nothing else out there not even
matter the universe closed its doors a
long time ago this place can go from
information back to matter with just the
Press of a button
let's see what happens when we introduce
something to nothing for a second it
looks as though he might fall but he
doesn't instead he slams the button on
the jukebox and with a relieve laugh
says let there be light and there was
light it's a natural instinct in many
species to protect their young and
sometimes it's not just their own babies
but any young that look like them
regardless of your personal feelings on
humans earliest stage it is a scientific
fact that human babies are designed to
emphasize their own adorable
helplessness to make sure that other
older humans take care of them a baby's
cry is an inherently distressing sound
and when we hear it some deep Primal
part of us feels the urge to comfort and
care for the child until the sound stops
but of course we're talking about the
world of the SCP Foundation here where
there are bunnies that can eat anything
teddy bears that might steal your organs
to make duplicates of themselves and
chocolate fountains filled with
trillions of murderous insects Nothing
Is What It Seems here and even the most
innocent and cute creatures may be
hiding A Deadly Secret
scp-734 being no exception today we're
talking about the baby this anomaly
proves that dangerous things can come in
small packages but where others only saw
misery and death the SCP Foundation saw
a certain potential Our Story begins in
the maternity ward of a hospital in the
USA where every medical professional's
worst nightmare was unfolding an unknown
but incredibly fast-acting flesh-eating
pathogens seemed to be running rampant
across the hospital's population it
began when patients who weren't even
admitted for Dermatological issues
started complaining of severe itches and
extreme skin pain some nurses and
doctors in the Maternity Ward began to
experience similar symptoms as well as
one of the infants leading to a massive
quarantine effort while the initial
symptoms first appear to be limited to
severe pain and discomfort on isolated
parts of the skin the condition of The
Afflicted soon escalated their skin
began to messily flake off as the cells
comprising it lost physical cohesion and
died it was a kind of strange anomalous
rot that seemed to work inwards first
destroying the Integrity of the outer
layer of skin and then cause further
disintegration to deeper parts of the
body once the skin had shut off the
pathogen would turn its attention to
what was lying beneath Against All Odds
the disease affected organs muscle
tissue the vascular system and even
bones nothing was spared the victim's
bodies would completely break down and
they would be dead within a few hours by
the time the pathogen had finished
ravaging its victims what was left
didn't even look human anymore not only
patients but doctors and nurses that
have been walking the wards mere hours
before were now little more than piles
of human tissue sitting in what had
previously been their hospital beds
whatever this was it seemed like the
fastest progressing infection in
recorded history Hospital staff and
administrators were terrified this
appeared to be an entirely new disease
with a mysterious form of transmission
and worst of all no cure they were even
more confused when several black vans
pulled up outside the hospital and
mysterious men in hazmat suits Spilled
Out and began setting up a quarantine
Zone around the entire building whoever
these strange people were they
definitely weren't the CDC little did
the hospital Personnel know that this
was the group you'd never watch showing
up and putting your location on lockdown
it was the SCP Foundation the infected
remains of the victims were taken away
for research purposes and the foundation
operatives immediately began conducting
debriefing in interviews with Witnesses
they soon determine from a mix of
eyewitness accounts and Hospital
surveillance footage that everyone
infected with a mysterious pathogen had
all been in a particular section of the
Maternity Ward earlier in the day and
when the operatives investigated this
area they found another strange detail
an infant had no registered mother
present in the hospital the foundation
would later learn that this was likely
because the baby's mother was the first
victim of the deadly disease after
eliminating all other possible options
it seemed that the only anomalous
element that could have caused all of
this was the mysterious baby though just
how the mother even survived carrying
the baby to term was a mystery in and of
itself the baby was a Caucasian male
human infant between seven and eight
months of age nothing appeared outwardly
anomalous about the child but they could
confirm that every single victim of the
anomalous pathogen had come into
physical contact with the child earlier
that day everyone who had been at the
hospital was given amnestic treatment
and the foundation constructed plausible
cover stories for the deaths that had
occurred that day like so many others
before it the child was secured and
Spirited Away to the nearest applicable
Foundation containment site there was
reclassified
scp-734 and finally the real testing
into what precisely this infant was
capable of could begin physiologically
scp-734 appeared mostly non-anomalous
the infant had above average
intelligence and physical aptitude for a
child his age but otherwise showed no
mutations or abnormalities that would
suggest a Divergence from typical human
biology despite a vast array of tests
performed by the foundation into
essentially every aspect of 734's
biology they couldn't find anything that
hinted at the origin of the mysterious
pathogen but through some trial and
extremely costly error the foundation
was able to learn more about how exact
exactly the pathogen worked the only
Vector for transmission seemed to be
direct contact with the baby itself up
to and including the fluids and residues
it leaves behind those affected cannot
transmit the anomalous flaking effect to
others meaning the risk of an epidemic
is relievingly minimal but of course
accidents still happen as was discovered
when one agent misplaced her Sympathy
for the baby and decided to remove her
mask while interacting with him her
logic was that her masked face might
have caused the baby some kind of
distress and as long as she was only
coming into contact with him via her own
gloved hands everything would be fine
but some dust particles were floating in
the air at the time and scp-734 sneezed
in her face the agent began screaming in
pain and recoiling from the baby but it
was already too late her fate was sealed
she was taken to the infirmary and given
sedative so that she could hopefully die
in as little pain as possible in roughly
70 two percent of cases amputation of
the affected areas has prevented the
entire body from succumbing to the
anomalous effects of
scp-734 but this isn't exactly feasible
where the point of contact is the
victim's head within hours the agent's
flesh had flaked off her face leaving
her looking like a red bloody skull a
few hours after that she didn't have a
head at all throughout the
disintegration process of this
unfortunate agent the foundation took
grisly photographs these photographs are
shown to anyone preparing to work on the
scp-734 research project to teach them a
hard lesson on the importance of
adhering to proper safety protocols and
these protocols about how to deal with
the baby are incredibly tight given that
even incidental contact is often a death
sentence anyone entering the baby's
containment chamber needs to wear
contained atmosphere hazmat suits anyone
who makes physical contact with the baby
even when suited up is immediately move
from the area and subject to several
hours of quarantine and observation even
inanimate objects that have been inside
the containment chamber need to be
thoroughly sterilized before being
removed given that even anomalous
children like scp-734 have very delicate
needs a Handler is always standing by in
full Hazmat gear to take care of the
baby these handlers are rotated every
hour to maintain alertness and safety
these handlers feed and change scp-734
regularly and sometimes even provide
toys that have been approved by the o5
council the foundation has gone to Great
Lengths to keep scp-734 alive and
comfortable because they believe that
scp-734 could be an important asset for
them in the future or more specifically
they see great strategic value in
scp-734's blood as mentioned earlier
contact with any matter from scp-734
triggers its deadly anomalous effects
including bodily fluids like blood but
unlike many toxic pathogens in this case
there is no risk of the infection
getting out of control since the
infected do not become vectors for
transmission because of this the blood
of scp-734 can act as a powerful weapon
for both terminating anomalies deemed
unviable by the o5 council and
assassinating dangerous people who
belong to rival Grooms contact with the
blood would completely destroy the
target's body with no other anomalous
effects and no evidence of who exactly
conducted the hit
scp-734 has been fitted with an arterial
catheter so that the foundation can
collect large quantities of blood from
the anomalous infant every single week
for storage and research but it isn't
just the blood that the foundation sees
potential in
scp-734 himself has scored incredibly
well on the Esslinger loyalty index the
test the foundation uses to judge the
Loyalty of potential applicants to the
foundation cause as SCP p734 matures if
these scores remain consistent you will
likely be trained to become a foundation
field agent in the future an agent
capable of killing someone with a touch
would needless to say be an asset to
certain covert missions that the
foundation would probably prefer to keep
off the books of course the SCP
Foundation recruiting certain compliant
anomalies to perform missions for them
is far from unprecedented the most
infamous of these is
scp-076 also known as able a
supernatural eternally resurrecting
swordsman and perhaps one of the finest
Warriors who ever lived the foundation
took note of this and channeled his
eternal thirst for battle into working
with his very own mobile task force he
could assist in missions by taking out
his bloodlust on enemy groups of
interest and dangerous anomalies however
this ended up working a little too well
and led to disaster Abel was so good at
his job that he burned through all of
his allotted Missions at astonishing
speed left with nothing more to do Abel
got antsy which led him to turning his
murderous desires on his fellow team
members and then the foundation as a
whole it was an all-out Massacre before
his colleagues were finally able to kill
him and return him to containment the
failure of this initiative gave the very
idea of letting anomalies work for the
foundation in the field a bad name but
since then things have changed
especially with the establishment of MTF
Alpha 9 AKA Last Hope a new mobile task
force formed entirely of anomalous
individuals and their handlers these
consist of somewhat more stable
anomalies such as Abel's counterpart
scp-073 also known as Kane Kane cannot
be harmed with any harm befalling him
simply being mirrored back on his
attacker and his vast array of knowledge
makes him an incredibly useful
intelligent asset another of the several
members of Last Hope is Iris also known
as
scp-105 much like k Iris not only has
anomalous powers that make her immensely
valuable from missions in the field
she's also compliant and capable of
listening to reason unlike Kane her
abilities include being able to actively
surveil and even interact with photos of
any location especially when taken with
her anomalous camera someday scp-734
could count himself among other
anomalous Foundation agents like these
providing he continues to show promise
and doesn't develop a dislike of the
foundation as he ages since after all he
won't be a baby forever so if you ever
find yourself on the foundation's bad
side you have a good reason to be
paranoid you'll have no idea that one
day the man who's going to kill you will
approach and shake your hand with a
smile it won't be until later when you
feel that strange tingle on your palm
and feel the skin starting to flake away
that you'll realize you've been a dead
man walking for hours imagine knowing
that there's a monster right under your
nose imagine knowing that this monster
is capable of killing any human being on
Earth and all because they simply saw a
photograph of its face when this monster
is on the warpath literally nothing can
stop it no weapon that human beings have
invented is capable of even slowing it
down imagine knowing in the age of mass
media of clicks and shares of 24-hour
news smartphones and Limitless social
media connecting billions across the
globe that one stray picture of this
monster leaked in the wrong place could
cause the end of the world as we know it
and this fateful terrifying day could
come at any time congratulations you now
know how it feels to be Dr Dan the
hot-headed lead SCP Foundation
researcher on the
scp-096 case the anomaly itself requires
no real introduction action the infamous
Mass murdering shy guy has haunted the
nightmares of foundation experts for
years but nobody is more haunted by this
thing than Dr Dan himself for over a
decade now he has firmly believed that
there's one solution to the 096 problem
termination with extreme prejudice in
his eyes to think that 096 is ever truly
contained is an illusion they could
never be sure of how many pictures of it
are out there floating around just
waiting to be seen like a time bomb
waiting to go off the resources spent
containing it and cleaning up after its
Rampages he would often argue would be
better spent instead figuring out how to
finally kill it but seeing as we're
talking about the SCP Foundation here
not the global occult Coalition the o5
council didn't see it quite the same way
they constantly overturned Dr Dan's
termination requests leaving the
paranoid researcher more furious with
each rejection he tried to warn them
again and again and again don't you see
it's like a stick of dynamite and the
fuse is already lit if you don't let me
put it out before it's too late there
won't even be anyone left to pick up the
pieces but his pleas fell on deaf ears
until of course
incident096-1-a A Dark and Bloody day
still looked back on with shame and
Horror by even the most hardened members
of Foundations staff it was the day that
scp-096 gave everyone a taste of the
mass Carnage it was truly capable of Dr
Dan wasn't even there when containment
was first breached it was off on an
expedition in the snowy mountains where
096 was first found trying to discover
Clues to its true origin Dr Dan's second
in command Dr Alexi was also lucky
enough to be outside of the containment
area when the shy guy escaped according
to enter reviews he gave at debriefing
tribunals he was in the break room
treating himself to a warm cup of joe
all the other Personnel assigned to
096's containment and research were near
its containment chamber a giant cube
made of reinforced metal observing a
live feed of data being collected from
the Cube's interior as usual sensors
indicated that 096 was pacing within for
obvious reasons the foundation doesn't
maintain any kind of live visual
surveillance on zero nine six it
wouldn't be worth the risk but what
seemed like an otherwise quiet day
suddenly took a turn for the insane the
monitors began displaying terrifying
data indicating an imminent Containment
Breach as the whales of the creature
within the cube echoed out through its
metal walls some try to run others did
all they could to engage emergency
procedures while guards armed with heavy
Weaponry rushed into the room they all
knew in their hearts that it wouldn't
save them but what else could they do a
huge dent bulged down from the side of
the cube then in another before the
metal was torn open like tissue paper as
the Furious hands of the shy guy began
clawing their way through it secondary
layers of protection were deployed but
they didn't help 096 just kept ripping
through all the barriers has everyone in
attendance knew once it was in its rage
State nothing could stop it literally
nothing the guards attempted to fire on
the anomaly but their bullets did no
good as the creature burst free most of
the people in the room had at least
momentary visual contact with its face
in Response Code Lima was declared and
the entire chamber was flooded with a
fast-acting nerve gas killing everyone
everyone except for 096 itself of course
within two minutes 096 had broken free
of the entire containment site and began
running through the desert at Breakneck
speeds towards its distant Target the
foundation needed to act fast and find a
way to stop it before it hit a
population Center where the death toll
would Skyrocket Team Echo Romeo were
dispatched to pursue the creature in a
heavily armed attack helicopter while
MTF Tau 1 a task force specializing in
scp-096 containment and Recovery forged
ahead to identify the anomaly's target
designated 096-1 and to move any other
civilians out of Harm's Way Dr Dan was
alerted of the disastrous situation and
offered guidance to both teams from afar
Echo Romeo's Chopper pursued 096 barely
able to keep up Dr Dan recommended
attempting to at least slow the creature
down with heavy arms fire even though he
knew actually stopping it would be
impossible a member of the team used a
modified xm-500 anti-material rifle to
fire several rounds at the creature but
even the shot that passed directly
through its head appeared to have no
effect on it but at least they had a
lock on its direction now 0 0.096 always
travels in a straight line directly
towards its Target smashing through any
obstacles in its way this means its
intended direction is relatively easy to
track and people in the path of its
trajectory are even easier to save but
it's a high pressure job reserve for MTF
Tau 1. Tao 1 passed over Echo Romeo and
096 and the series of 8v22 Ospreys
hoping Beyond hope that they could
outrun the creature since there were
several different towns in its direct
path but thanks once again to the one
and only Dr Dan Echo Romeo and Taiwan
had a secret weapon that neither team
had ever possessed before scramble
scramble was an advanced computer
program created by Dr Dan with the help
of Dr Alexi which was coded into
microprocessors for modification into
camera feeds and viewing goggles the
program had been fed intricate data
concerning every single detail of 096's
face and as the name suggests when
encountering that visual data in real
life it scrambles it beyond recognition
in theory it would make it far safer for
operatives to be around
scp-096 without activating its rage
state in theory it wasn't long before
disaster struck 096 had made its way
onto I-40 and had begun attacking
vehicles that encountered killing the
people inside by this point it had
already outrun the echo Romeo Chopper
rendering them essentially useless
talwan just had a forge ahead along
096's trajectory and try to get as many
people out of the danger zone as
possible until 096-1 was located and
destroyed by the anomaly years of
training for an awful day like this had
paid off as the first three towns along
096's path were successfully evacuated
the shy guy just ran right through all
of them and no lives were lost the same
however could not be said for Town
number four as was standard procedure
talwan had everyone in the town gathered
up and blindfolded the entire team in
attendance had modified night vision
goggles with scramble microprocessors So
in theory they were better off than most
from 096 if things went South the talwan
members tried in vain to keep everybody
in line they were threatening to shoot
anyone who dared to remove their
blindfold when 096 finally appeared it
tripped during its approach rolling and
shattering through several houses chaos
erupted some people instinctively
removed their blindfolds to see what was
going on and panic members of Taiwan
began firing into the crowd the screams
of the civilians and the bursts of
gunfire were all drowned out by the
horrific whaling of 096 itself as it
tore through everyone and everything to
kill the Unfortunate Souls who had seen
its face and given how many had removed
their blindfolds during the initial
pandemonium
scp-096 had a huge number of the
townspeople on its list 096 located and
grab the original 096-1 the person that
had first glimpsed its face and caused
all of this but in the grand scheme of
things he was just one more body on the
pile that day though of course we mean
this in a purely metaphorical sense 096
never leaves entire bodies the
foundation operatives in attendance were
able to figure out what had caused all
this madness and death 096-1 had been an
amateur Mountaineer and spent his
vacations hiking around any mountain
ranges he could gain access to including
the mountain range that 096 had been
inhabiting prior to its initial capture
and containment but he hadn't actually
seen 096 on that fateful trip which had
been taken over a decade ago but in a
photograph taken that day of himself
standing on a picturesque Mountainside
096 made a cameo it took up all of four
pixels a tiny off-white dog against the
snow on the back right side of the
photograph this photograph with all the
deadly potency of an atom bomb had been
sitting there for years waiting when the
Mountaineer was looking through old
photos that morning and his eyes passed
over those few blurry pixels he didn't
have any idea that he had just laid his
eyes on one of the most dangerous
anomalies the world has ever seen but
you don't have to know only 096 does as
Taiwan led by their Commander Major Jack
Wilford tried to retake control of the
situation things got even worse it
turned out Dr Dan's scramble technology
the one thing that was supposed to have
given them an edge in this situation
didn't actually work as soon as goggle
wearing members of the team laid eyes on
096 it entered its rage State and
started massacring them it tore many of
the mobile task force members to shreds
including a number of the operatives
required for piloting the Adas freeze it
was a disaster of truly epic proportions
and the catastrophic failure of Dr Dan's
scramble technology was a key factor the
root of the Technology's failure was
easy enough to figure out Dr Dan's
scramble microprocessors worked fast but
not fast enough fractions of a second
glimpses of 096's face managed to get
through and that was more than enough to
set 096 off Echo Romeo and MTF Epsilon
arrive shortly afterwards to clean up
the mess it'd been a disaster of such
magnitude that even a CNN reporter
arrived on the scene and started filming
before being promptly shut down by
Epsilon it was a member of echo Romeo
that finally slipped the bag over a
docile 096's head preparing it for
containment once again the creature now
content that it had eliminated all the
Unfortunate Souls who had seen its face
he'd found 096 sitting next to a minivan
that had its roof ripped off the young
family inside being the last to have
seen its face and things were so awful
in the aftermath of the Containment
Breach that the o5 council changed their
tune finally granting Dr Dan permission
to terminate 096 by any means necessary
it's terrifying to think that all this
can unfold because of a couple of poorly
timed accidents but it's probably even
more terrifying to consider that it
wasn't an accident at all it seemed
awfully convenient that both Dr Dan and
Dr Alexi were far from danger when all
hell broke loose it was also convenient
that despite the failure of his
technology being a major reason why the
breach was as deadly as it was Dr Dan
had still come out of the situation with
everything he wanted the foundation also
found this strange and the more they
looked into it the more they found
details that didn't add up Alibis began
to fall apart coincidences didn't seem
so coincidental and eventually a weak
Link in the chain was identified Dr
Alexi under pressure from the foundation
Alexi spilled everything Dr Dan had
essentially orchestrated the entire
Containment Breach and on top of that he
did everything he could to make it as
deadly as possible all with the purpose
of getting the o5 council to see things
his way and finally give him the
permission he needed to devote all the
scp-096 resources to its termination but
it came at a terrible price to Dr Dan
personally for his crimes against the
foundation and Humanity he was permitted
to try and figure out a way to terminate
096 once and for all but as payment for
his crimes he himself would also be
terminated as soon as his task was
complete where the lives of all those
innocent people and Dr Dan himself worth
the price of finally being authorized to
terminate
scp-096 when asked why he did all of
this Dr Dan simply said it worked there
was only a matter of time until that
happened in a major population Center
and its face spread over the world news
I can kill 096 but I've killed myself in
the process while we don't agree with
his methods there's something almost
admirable about a person so
single-mindedly devoted to their cause
on a cold October night in 2003 Shirley
Yates of Seattle Washington was just
about to get ready for bed when she
heard a knock at the door she approached
the door and asked the person on the
other side to identify themselves The
Voice outside responded immediately it
was a Salesman who just wanted a few
moments of Mrs Yates time this was odd
for two reasons first it was almost 10
o'clock at night much later than as
usual for door-to-door salesman and
second the knock hadn't come from Mrs
yates's front door it was coming from
the door to her bathroom has your home
ever been visited by a door-to-door
Salesman if you were born in the last 40
years than your answer to that question
is probably no in the age of online
shopping the idea of a salesperson going
from house to house Hocking vacuum
cleaners or encyclopedia sets Feels Like
A Relic from the past it's highly
unlikely you'd ever see one walking the
streets nowadays and equally unlikely
that one would knock on your front door
however if you live in Washington state
you might need to be wary of a certain
salesman who is still doing the rounds
scp-1879 also known as the indoor
salesman and the doorman is a phenomenon
that manifests randomly in homes
throughout Washington subjects will hear
persistent knocking from the interior
doors of their homes and the affected
door becomes classified as
scp-1879-1 the knocking doesn't stop
until the door is opened at which point
the subject will be greeted by
scp-1879-2 a Caucasian man of
indeterminate age standing around 170
centimeters tall the man will claim to
be a Salesman and immediately try to
pitch a bizarre product to the subject
whose home he's just invaded the SCP
Foundation was first alerted to the
existence of the indoor salesman when
they had intercepted a 9-1-1 call coming
from the home of Mrs Shirley Yates she
had opened the door to her bathroom in
an attempt to get the salesman to stop
knocking and once he was in her home he
refused to leave according to Yates he
kept disappearing in and out of random
doors in her house foundation field
agent Rogers was equipped with a
recording device and sent in to
investigate the case with several other
agents when he arrived at the home he
found Mrs Yates inconsolable
scp-1879-2 was still rapidly talking at
her and strangely enough the product he
was holding and trying to sell to her
was a Border Collie puppy as soon as
agent Rogers entered the room the man
shifted his attention away from Mrs
Yates and towards him he then started
trying to sell the puppy to agent Rogers
agent Rogers did not want to purchase
this puppy but he found that the man
spoke so quickly and urgently he
couldn't get a word in edgewise the man
was begging Rogers to take the puppy
practically shoving it in his face
saying that he didn't need any money and
that the only payment he needed would be
some of your time Rogers grew so annoyed
at being talked over and interrupted
that he ordered the other field agents
to apprehend the indoor salesman they
did so but as soon as the agents walked
him out of the front door of the house
he disappeared without a trace the
agents remained in the area to monitor
the situation
scp-1879-2 manifested again in Mrs
yates's home six hours later still
trying to trade the puppy for no money
just a little of her time 12 years to be
precise after hours and hours of being
worn down by this supernaturally pushy
salesman Yates relented and agreed to
take the puppy and immediately
disappeared the indoor salesman then
disappeared himself through the closet
door before he could be apprehended
again at a loss for what to do the
agents administered Class A amnestics to
Mrs yates's family and left the reason
for her disappearance wasn't fully known
until 12 years later in 2015 when she
reappeared in the same spot she
disappeared from having no concept of
how much time had passed the puppy
really had just cost her 12 years of her
life stories like that of Shirley Yates
have popped up all over the state in the
years since from Everett to Walla Walla
and everywhere in between due to the
random nature of
scp-1879 events and the way the indoor
salesman can disappear instantly in and
out of any door in the building the SCP
Foundation has been unable to capture
him the best they've been able to do is
Monitor 9-1-1 calls from across the
state listening for key words that might
indicate another
scp-1879 infestation when such an event
is supported the foundation deploys
mobile task force Row 4 AKA shoes
salesman this task forces entire purpose
is to minimize the amount of harm the
indoor salesman is able to cause by
intercepting him before he can make a
sale this is a very important task as
evidenced by the story of Mrs Yates
since while the products this salesman
sells might be innocent he doesn't
accept payment in any normal currency
the price he asks for his products are
always bizarre and often deadly if all
someone loses is 12 years of their life
they could be considered to be getting
off easy in one instance the product
being sold was a single red rose in
exchange for the subject's harp once the
deal was sealed the subject dropped dead
on the spot with an autopsy revealing
that his heart and circulatory system
vanished from inside his body in another
the indoor salesman offered 220 bananas
and told the subject to Simply give him
some sugar the subject agreed and all
candied goods and the home disappeared
in a third the indoor salesman was
trying to sell a thermonuclear Warhead
the price of which was the subject's
soul the subject accepted and at first
nothing seemed to have happened the
foundation confiscated the Warhead and
placed it into non-anomalous containment
later that day the subject went to
listen to some music only to find that
two of her vinyl records had gone
missing Lady Soul and Almighty Fire by
world famous soul singer Aretha Franklin
so even though he's incredibly invasive
annoying and his transactions can be
deadly the indoor salesman still
maintains a sense of humor the fact that
the foundation can't capture the indoor
salesman means that a lot of questions
about him remain unanswered the biggest
by far is why he does what he does in
most
scp-1879 events the indoor salesman
seems frantic and desperate to make a
sale often he will refer to having
quotas and deadlines to meet which
implies some other her unseen entity
that he has to answer to these questions
remain unanswered because all attempts
to interrogate the indoor salesmen have
been unsuccessful when he manifests in
the location it's impossible to get him
to stray from a sales pitch and he
disappears as soon as he successfully
sells his Wares however there was one
instance where after an
scp-1879 event took place Foundation
agents were there to witness a rare
interaction between the indoor salesman
and his mysterious employers agent
Rogers and the rest of the shoes
salesmen were called out to a home in
Spokane where rapid knocking had begun
to emanate from the bedroom door
equipped with recording devices Rogers
was able to record the voice of the
indoor salesman coming from inside the
bedroom in the recording the salesman
grumbled to himself about not being able
to meet his quota by tomorrow saying
that if he didn't he'd be stuck in this
world for the next Century he started
knocking again yelling through the door
that he knew they were home he kept
knocking until he was interrupted by the
sound of a phone ringing the indoor
salesman Was Heard picking it up and
Rogers managed to record the
conversation the person calling was
apparently the indoor salesman's boss
who was calling to complain about his
performance only one side of the
conversation was heard but evidently the
indoor salesman's boss wasn't too happy
about receiving two Aretha Franklin
albums as payment instead of an actual
human soul the indoor salesman
apologized for the joke then told his
boss it won't happen again please don't
head it I'll meet the quota this time I
swear he hung up grumbling to himself
again I better get to move up to at
least accounting this time I've paid my
dues and then some Rogers finally opened
the door to the apparent disappointment
of the indoor salesman who was hoping to
speak with the home's owner and was
quite annoyed at having another one of
his sales interrupted by MTF row 4.
Rogers tried to ask the indoor salesman
who he'd just been speaking to on the
phone but as usual the salesman started
talking over him now see here let's
think logically he said you know I'm not
going to tell you anything I know you're
not likely to buy what I'm selling so
let's just move on to greener pastures
I'm coming up close to a deadline and
I'm sure you're swamped with making sure
good people don't lose that job so I'll
just be on my way and let you do that
ciao the indoor salesman tried to close
the door but agent Rogers blocked it
with his arm he was tired of this SCP
giving him the runaround and he was
going to keep the indoor salesman here
if it was the last thing he did he
demanded The Entity stay and be
interviewed and other members of the
task force apprehended the salesman
making sure he couldn't leave the room
the indoor salesman now held in place by
several armed men seemed to finally
relent he told Rogers I'm busy so I'll
tell you what I'm gonna give you
something no money out of your pocket
and we'll call it even sound good Roger
is just wanting to get this whole thing
over with agreed to those terms three
seconds later every agent on the scene
was dead and the indoor salesman was
able to straighten his tie pick up his
briefcase and walk through the door to
the bathroom when the bodies of agent
Rogers and the rest of the MTF Row 4
were examined by Foundation scientists
the cause of death was found to be in
every case thousands of coins suddenly
appearing in not only their pockets but
also inside their stomachs lungs and
even under their skin later that day the
indoor salesman was reported at a home
in the same neighborhood he was seen
trying to sell The house's owner 80 year
old retiree Alan Johnson a Glock 18
pistol in exchange for his attention as
he had done so many times before the
indoor salesman disappeared through
another door before the foundation was
able to reach the scene and when the SCP
arrived they found Mr Johnson's still
alive but now missing his prefrontal
cortex the part of the brain that
controls attention it's likely that
because of the nature of the entity
scp-1879 might be in entirely impossible
to contain the foundation might never
find out anything more than what they
already know about the indoor salesman
the way he's able to manifest behind
closed doors or the reason he has to
keep filling quotas for an unseen boss
who apparently doesn't have a very good
sense of humor so if you're ever in
Washington state be careful who you open
your doors to especially if the knocking
you hear is coming from inside your
house let's start off with a difficult
question how do you define reality what
is truly real is it simply a case of
what we can see if something is known as
fact and can be proven to exist does
this make it real is reality just the
world around us or is there something
more the goal of these questions isn't
to make you question every part of the
world around you or to question whether
or not we are all living in a computer
simulation no you're asked the is to
help you understand reality because
first of all we aren't living in a
simulation we're living in a sitcom
there is a wide-ranging debate on what
the most powerful and dangerous scps
ever encountered are but there is no
denying the ever-present danger of
scp-3812 this cutter class entity is
regarded as highly aggressive by the o5
council especially as it has only ever
been partially contained never fully the
true scope of its abilities is currently
unknown and any available information on
scp-3812 is kept classified and secure
by the foundation needless to say this
entity poses a direct threat not only to
the SCP Foundation but to the very
fabric of reality itself contained
within the file for scp-3812 is an
excerpt from an article by one Dr Robert
Scranton titled super session and the
echelon of reality in this article Dr
Scranton posits a theory about the
nature of reality and understanding him
is the first step towards understanding
scp-3812 his recursive stack theory
states that there are different layers
to reality but also that no single
universe is real an easy way to think of
it is to imagine a sitcom any sitcom you
can Envision will do between us and the
fictional world of a sitcom there are
multiple observable stacked universes
firstly our universe the real world as
we experience it forms the Baseline so
imagine this sitting at the top of the
stack next down in the stack comes the
sitcom a fictional Universe filled with
characters which fits below our universe
then think of what is fiction within the
fiction of the sitcom perhaps another
television show one that only exists in
the world of the sitcom but not in our
own this is the recursive stack
infinitely layered universes and it is
crucial you can Envision and remember
this model DR Scranton's Theory suggests
that any Universe even our own could
potentially exist as a fictional
narrative within another wider Universe
this wider Universe in which ours is a
fiction could also itself be a narrative
within an even wider Universe stacked
above it and so on it's interesting to
picture reality this way isn't it in
fact I'm willing to bet that you're
wondering maybe there's a universe above
ours or even one above that with the
universe right at the top of the stack
be the truly real world and what if you
could travel between each stacked
reality if you're asking any of those
questions then congratulations you sound
exactly like
scp-3812
scp-3812 was previously known as Sam
Howell while little is known about his
life Sam was as far as anyone knew
regarded as a fairly ordinary human
being until his death in 1996 shortly
after which Sam Rose from his grave and
disappeared appeared it is unknown
whether scp-3812 simply imitated the
form of Sam Howell or if they are one
and the same as this entity has been
known to have the ability to change
forms at will making it hard for the
foundation to track it it does usually
maintain a humanoid appearance however
this has deteriorated somewhat over
numerous decades by now you may have
already gathered that the extent of
scp-3812's abilities don't end at
shape-shifting this SCP is a powerful
aggressive reality altering entity cast
your mind back to the recursive stack
scp-3812 is able to travel upwards
through these stacked universes creating
Untold chaos using its plethora of world
bending abilities as far as the SCP
Foundation can tell 3812's sole
intention is to become an omnipotent
Force existing above any and all
possible universes in other words the
top of the stack aside from the ability
to change shape as
cp3812's control and alteration of a
reality around it is achieved by its
long list of latent abilities this
entity is capable of Feats far beyond
that of normal humans such as
teleportation telekinesis and telepathy
however scp-3812 is also able to
directly manipulate any and all aspects
of reality it can influence an alter
observable forces around us for example
the manipulation of matter energy
weather and even gravity and other laws
of physics as we know them but the
creature can also warp reality on
further levels it's able to erase people
objects or even Concepts to the point
where human beings lose virtually all
memory of them with the danger that an
entity this powerful poses to our
reality it's not surprising that the SCP
Foundation would attempt to nullify its
abilities one attempt by the foundation
involved another unknown SCP which
created an anti-metaphysical field this
was done in the hopes that it would
strip SC
scp-3812 of its reality warping
abilities however the entity was unfazed
the containment attempt failed and the
remains of the unknown SCP instead
resulted in the creation of
scp-239 as for the scp-3812 entity's own
origin that is still largely unknown but
there does exist a message on a secure
server in the SCP foundation's o5
command seemingly from another entity
belonging to a reality stacked higher
above our own that appears to have
created a reality much further down one
that scp-3812 inhabited and now it seems
that scp-3812 is climbing up the stack
there is a trade-off of sorts to the
abundance of powers
scp-3812 possesses The Entity is in an
almost constant state of Ascension
through different stacked universes
climbing higher and higher believing
every reality beneath it to be a fiction
the creature has developed multiple
severe mental conditions that seem
seemed to be a direct result of
overexposure to different layers of
reality this includes an advanced form
of enigman theater schizophrenia complex
which often manifests in extreme
symptoms within the creature
scp-3812 has been known to suffer from
paranoia dysphoria depression and
inability to control its emotions as
well as hearing voices seeing things
that do not exist and possessing
multiple personalities while the
creature is usually aimless
scp-3812 has been known to have random
outbursts that can cause anomalies
within local space and time but thanks
to it experiencing so many different
layers of reality traveling upwards
through what it perceives to be
fictional universes
scp-3812 displays difficulty in
separating what is real and what is
imagined in fact reality and fiction
have become one in the same to scp-3812
because as far as it is concerned they
literally are the same each new reality
it inhabits is just fiction for the
reality stacked above it so then how are
we supposed to contain or neutralize
such a powerful reality altering
creature that cannot distinguish between
what is real and what is fictional the
foundation knows that its own procedures
to keep scp-3812 contained would be
ineffective this entity by its nature
cannot be contained any attempt to keep
it locked away would easily be undone by
any one of its numerous powers to warp
reality locking it in a cement box at
the bottom of the ocean would be
pointless it could teleport out or turn
itself into nothing but dust putting it
in a vat of acid to endlessly burn it
would just result in it turning that
acid to harmless water or air
scp-3812 can manipulate events
throughout time and so it could easily
prevent itself from ever being contained
it is even possible that any individuals
even Foundation staff who may have
previously tried to lock the creature up
now no longer exists thanks to
scp-3812's abilities and there would be
no way to determine this since we
wouldn't be able to remember that the
person had ever been in our reality the
foundation's best hope is to keep
scp-3812 where it is and hope it remains
docile if they are able to keep it away
from large population centers then the
risk of 3812 having any sort of psychic
influence over citizens or warping
reality and causing the deaths of
millions or even billions is at least
reduced but of course it is never fully
gone on at least one occasion
scp-3812 has caused a truly catastrophic
event for some reason
scp-3812 decided to turn itself into a
star spinning endlessly and it did so
numerous anomalous occurrences took
place across the world most notably
scp-3812 caused the foundation's nuclear
warheads to detonate spreading harmful
radioactive material into the atmosphere
Additionally the population of New
Zealand began to sporadically disappear
and reappear looping back and forth
between existence and non-existence for
a period of around five hours it was
during this world ending scenario that
scp-3812 still at the center of its star
form was recorded ranting its split
personalities arguing one of the
creature's personalities claimed it was
unmaking the world as an act of revenge
against someone it stated that it
believed existence is a joke The
Narrative abandoned us to be miserable
and we are breaking the narrative its
other half mentioned another entity
known only as Ben and seemed to imply
that this entity was responsible for
scp-3812's creation in a reality stacked
above this one according to the more
rational of 3812's two halves this Ben
entity deemed us unfit to rest
peacefully to slip into the darkness
quietly he made a game of us it then
went on to convince this other half that
destroying this reality just a slight
Bend would be pointless there would
always be another stacked on top
infinitely so why does this narrative
mean anything to you it asked it is one
of an eternity to others it is not
special it is not particular the two
sides of scp-3812 argued with each other
one wanting to destroy all of reality to
spite Ben driven mad by witnessing
trillions upon trillions of universes
stacked atop each other the other half
of 3812 saw peace for itself ascending
above these infinitely stacked universes
finally reaching the top and becoming
free not a god a star rising in the East
Rising away from this all until we are
Little More Than A Memory of a song it
will be lonely the other half of the
creature replied We'll have each other
scp-3812's other personality said I'm
afraid said the one intent on
destruction I am too the other reassured
it but that is no reason to just destroy
this narrative eventually
scp-3812's personalities reached
agreement they both left the narrative
they were currently in presumably
traveling upwards to one stacked above
our own while simultaneously remaining
in this universe still a danger let go
of this world let him rewrite it back to
what it was we aren't part of this
anymore shortly after this event reality
shifted once more and the entire world
reverted back to how it had been before
records of the end of the world scenario
that had occurred were retained by
high-level administrators and the o5
council perhaps as a reminder of the
destructive capabilities of the creature
a warning of its potential to change
this reality and any stacked below or
above it fortunately since this incident
scp-3812 has remained in its docile
aimless State no longer actively hostile
to anyone that approaches it it has kept
its amorphous star-like shape and is
still very much able to create
disruptions and anomalies in reality
despite keeping scp-3812 constantly
monitored at its current location in the
South Pacific Ocean the SCP Foundation
knows that at any time this entity could
trigger yet another Global catastrophe
causing massive damage to planet Earth
its population and beyond that tearing
our reality itself asunder so we all
just better hope our narrative remains
worthwhile to
scp-3812's better half
it's a perfect day for a wedding on a
warm spring afternoon a bride in a
handsome groom are exchanging the
special Rings they had custom designed
and made for each other as they take
turns placing the rings on each other's
fingers a man standing at the end of the
wedding party steps out of position he
approaches the groomsmen next to him and
reaches into his jacket taking out a
pair of pliers that he hands to the
groomsmen the groomsmen happily takes
the tool and then without any hesitation
shoves the pliers into his mouth and
begins removing his teeth one by one
when he is finished he hands the bloody
teeth to the man along with the pliers
the man then goes to the next groomsmen
who repeats the same process he
continues going down the line until all
of the groomsmen and bridesmaids have
removed their teeth seemingly without
pain or resistance the man then
approaches the bride and groom he hands
each of them half of the pile of teeth
which they gladly accept they then begin
to eat the teeth without delay seemingly
not bothered by the intense damage
they're causing to their own teeth and
Jaws by doing so the man watches as the
groom moves the priest who is
officiating the wedding aside as the
entire church looks on in Joy the groom
opens his mouth and the deafening sound
of cicadas are heard this is only the
beginning of what the SCP Foundation has
labeled an
scp-2852 event a terrifying and little
understood phenomenon that is better
known by the nickname of the anomalous
creature responsible for them cousin
Johnny the foundation had been trying to
contain cousin Johnny for decades not
that it'd ever done them any good Johnny
is a cutter class anomaly that's thus
far proven impossible to contain this is
an entity so dangerous and volatile that
three different mobile task forces are
devoted to detecting and disrupting its
activities MTF Upsilon 36 aka the party
crashers MTF upsalon 50 2 AKA cater Duty
and MTF Upsilon 99 AKA The Altar Boys
but so far all the foundation has been
able to really do is swooping afterwards
and do their best to pick up the pieces
of people's shattered lives cousin
Johnny has so far been observed to only
operate in the North American
subcontinent and only seems to appear at
Anglican or Catholic baptisms weddings
and funerals however Foundation
operatives charged with keeping a lid on
cousin Johnny Harbor the hidden fear
that he may one day expand his hunting
grounds and wreck Terror worldwide if
Johnny became multinational or
multi-denominational his violence
insanity and pure evil May truly become
impossible to minimize so compatible
communities are constantly monitored for
increased levels of juvenile delinquency
sterility domestic violence and divorce
after all this you're probably wondering
who or what actually is cousin Johnny
and how does he cause so much horrific
tragedy had face value nothing about the
appearance of cousin Johnny would
suggest an anomalous nature or even any
sort of danger he appears to be a
middle-aged white male often with
scruffy hair and a beard on a cellular
level 2 cousin Johnny appears all too
human but when you look at his
physiology it's a whole different story
cousin Johnny has no identifiable organs
whatsoever his body is made out of a
fibrous muscular tissue the only
exceptions are his teeth and hair which
are made out of a kind of chitin a key
component of insect exoskeletons such as
those possessed by cicadas Johnny's eyes
are the first clue that something is off
about him from the distance they appear
perfectly normal but up close they're
glassy and dead this is because his eyes
aren't actually attached to any nerves
inside his head with no nervous system
or vocal cords Johnny's ability to see
move and talk defy any kind of logical
explanation his speech will seem
completely normal to the people under
his spell but to anyone one else it
comes out as complete nonsense often
described as word salad if people in
attendance are briefed in advance about
this phenomenon whatever hypnotic
ability causes them to hear his sounds
as intelligible words won't work and
they'll be aware of how nonsensical it
all sounds but of course that doesn't
mean they're safe cousin Johnny appears
at family gatherings and religious
rituals and immediately he'll be treated
as though he's always been there you
know your cousin Johnny right you go way
back or at least you're pretty sure you
do nothing will appear unnatural about
his sudden presence in fact if you're
one of the victims of one of his
incidents chances are you'll actually
find yourself taking a shine to cousin
Johnny sure his sense of humor is a
little crude and raunchy but you can't
help but enjoy his company he's a fun
guy to be around and after all he's
family as previously mentioned he'll
only appear at three different kinds of
events baptisms weddings and funerals
and only those that are affiliated with
either the Catholic or Anglican
religions the SCP Foundation has
classified baptisms that cousin Johnny
attends as blue level events weddings
are known as white level events and
funerals are Black Level events with
each one escalating in severity violence
and horror first baptisms the blue level
events in these events cousin Johnny
will appear and begin to act as a third
Godparent despite their traditionally
only being two as the infant is lowered
into the holy water the entirety of
their top layer of skin will come off
like a molting snake despite looking
horrific this apparently causes no harm
to the child the godparents will then
eat this discarded skin as though it's
the most normal thing in the world after
this the family will leave the church
together and cousin Johnny will leave
with them he won't appear at any
subsequent celebrations of the child's
baptism of course this is just the
beginning of the terror following cousin
Johnny's appearance at the baptism the
child's risk of dying in the next six
months skyrockets and if they survive
they're at an increased risk of becoming
unstable and violent later on in life
their parents and godparents will both
become unable to conceive any further
children and are likely to be found dead
from drowning within five years of the
event those who are only tangentially
involved in the baptism ritual have a
massively increased chance of failed
pregnancies or if they do conceive they
may become a danger to their offspring
children who live through blue level
events and survive past adolescents will
experience adverse side effects when
encountering the songs of cicadas well
into adulthood from experiencing
physical sickness to going through
dangerous psychotic episodes weddings or
white level events are more complex and
severe in this case cousin Johnny will
insert himself into the wedding as a
groomsman and the most horrifying events
will begin to take place after the vows
have been exchanged Johnny will provide
various implements that allow the
bridesmaids in groomsmen and to remove
their teeth which are then given to the
bride and groom to eat which they do
causing severe damage to their own teeth
in the process the groom will then
vocalize an unknown cicada call at an
incredible volume as loud as 140
decibels in some instances rendering the
bride and everyone else near the altar
completely death at the wedding
reception where everyone is continuing
to behave as if nothing out of the
ordinary is happening cousin Johnny will
ruin things farther by giving the best
man's speech the speech is more of his
typical complete nonsense though if
you're there you'll never realize this
and think that this is the best speech
you've ever heard with some in the
audience laughing hysterically While
others cry uncontrollably once his
speech is done he'll present a gift to
the newly married couple 3.5 kilograms
of human hair in various colors 13
deceased specimens of a certain cicada
known as lynnese cicada and 23 human
teeth in a cardboard box DNA tests on
all the gifts have been inconclusive of
us to their origin much like many
celebrity marriages unions that occurred
during white level events Never Last and
all end up divorced within two years
often as a result of domestic violence
and any children born during their brief
marriage will be violent and unstable
but it's not just a wedding party that
gets to experience the fun of a visit
from cousin Johnny all married
individuals who attended the wedding
will find that they are unable to
conceive children despite no biological
indicators of infertility any children
present at the white level event will
show no interest in Romance throughout
their life and often die tragically
before reaching the age of 18. finally
and most horrifying of all are funerals
or black level events while blue and
white level events can potentially be
disrupted before they are completed
lessening or preventing the horrific
results there is as yet no way to stop
or prevent a black level event at any
stage any attempts to prevent cousin
Johnny from entering the church or
Funeral Home will lead him to simply
manifesting inside once in the room
where the funeral is taking place cousin
Johnny will first take up the role of
eulogizer and begin speaking his
standard nonsense to the attendance the
person who was emotionally closest to
The Departed will then open the casket
if this was not already an open casket
funeral and will then produce a large
knife it's unknown where the knives come
from as they're not present before the
event and they disappear after the
funeral attendees will then use the
knife on their wrists and sometimes
throats draining their blood into the
coffin many lose more than enough blood
to result in death but none ever die
from this nor do they seem to feel any
pain from their wounds as the attendees
take turns bleeding into the coffin
cousin Johnny continues his eulogy which
eventually evolves into a cicada song
the kind song by lanae's cicada males
the attendants sing the same song back
to him in a kind of call and response
cousin Johnny will then approach the
coffin and vomit in a mixture of blood
wood pulp and dead cicadas the funeral
will then proceed as normal and the
blood vomit and cicada-filled casket is
then taken to the cemetery and buried
Black Level events will usually end with
the body being interred in the ground
but if there's a wake after the funeral
the horrors of the Black Level event
will continue at the Wake cousin Johnny
will climb on top of a table lie down
and encourage the other attendants to
devour him which they do all the while
he continues to talk his nonsense until
there is nothing left much like blue and
white level events being in attendance
leads to horrific After Effects all
participants who experience this event
will separate from their family through
either suicide moving or divorce every
individual Presence at the event will
also find that they are no longer able
to produce Offspring and couples
presence may also fall victim to
incidencies of domestic violence often
involving cannibalism that usually leave
one or both participants instead while 6
out of 10 children involved will attempt
to murder one or both of their parents
before they turn 18. these black level
events are so horrible for all involved
that any members of the specialized
cousin Johnny mobile task forces that
happen to witness such an event are
treated with class A amnestics before
they are transferred to another task
force or retire to ensure that they
don't have to live with the memories of
what they saw prior to that they are
closely monitored for any strange or
anti-social Behavior to make sure they
weren't affected by the event and they
aren't the only SCP Foundation staff at
risk of having been impacted by cousin
Johnny it is theorized that as many as a
third of Catholic and Anglican d-class
Personnel were involved in the Black
Level event at some point and were
driven to Madness and violence by their
fateful brushes with the strange
relative that no one knows so next time
you're out of baptism or a wedding or a
funeral stay vigilant keep an eye on the
other guests and always ask yourself do
you really have a cousin Johnny what is
the most dangerous thing you can imagine
an average person might say an apex
predator or a violent killer meanwhile a
researcher working for the SCP
Foundation might cite one of the XK
Class end of the world scenarios like
the release of the Devourer of Worlds as
the most dangerous thing they can
imagine but if you were to pose that
question to an astrophysicist ask what
they think is the most dangerous thing
they can imagine then you're likely to
get only one answer a black hole that
area of space that pulls in anything and
everything around it with its immense
gravity whether it's planets or
asteroids or even light itself nothing
can escape the pull of a black hole
around every black hole is an area known
as The Event Horizon and once you go
past this boundary there is no going
back if you were aboard a spacecraft
that ended up going past the event or
Horizon of a black hole you're
essentially as doomed as anyone can
possibly be according to certain laws of
quantum mechanics black holes do have
their own temperature and will often
emit what is known as Hawking radiation
named after the renowned physicist
Stephen Hawking given that black holes
absorb everything they will also pull
this radiation back into their own Mass
shrinking as they gradually collapse in
on themselves as for what's inside a
black hole hard to say anything can be
pulled into one but nothing can exist
within it or at least that's what the
world's leading scientists will tell you
other theories have been floating around
there on where black holes might lead
perhaps they might be doorways into
other universes and dimensions beyond
our understanding or maybe black holes
are gaps in the fabric of the space-time
Continuum and falling through one might
send you hurtling years into the future
or even the past and then
there's
scp-123 something that the foundation
keeps well guarded
scp-123 consists of a gray geodesic
sphere meaning it is a shape comprised
of various connected triangles kind of
like the Epcot Center built from an
unknown material the hollow sphere
housing scp-123 consists of 60 triangles
with empty spaces between that allow
someone to view the center within it is
what looks like a much smaller sphere
only around a single millimeter in
diameter this inner sphere is completely
black all over emitting zero light and
test by Foundation researchers have
revealed that this dark sphere will also
not reflect light either that's because
scp-123 is as you may have guessed a
contained miniature black hole much like
the larger black holes found throughout
the solar system the core of scp-123 has
a strong gravitational force capable of
gently pulling any objects that are
within three meters of the outer
geodesic sphere towards it any object
resting against the surface of the outer
sphere seems to become double its normal
weight as it gets caught up in the
powerful forces within however while the
pull of the black hole is at least
weakened somewhat by this outer layer
inside the casing the strength of the
black hole is dramatically increased you
would be smart to leave your keys wallet
and phone in another room if you were
approaching scp-123 has any small object
that can fit through the Triangular gaps
in the outer shell will be pulled into
the black hole in the center when
brought close enough solid objects will
rapidly accelerate as they are snatched
up by the force of the anomalous sphere
only for the object to vanish entirely
from view as it's lost to the void
within according to tests conducted by
Foundation research teams the same
occurs if liquid is ever poured through
one of the outer spheres gaps and it
will be sucked away into the black hole
like watered down a drain further
observations made by the foundation's
researchers confirmed that all light
near scp-123 curves towards the black
sphere in the center interestingly black
holes cannot normally be seen or
observed directly with the naked eye due
to them being able to pull in light so
instead astronomers and astrophysicists
will monitor changes in the area
surrounding a suspected black hole for
any notable changes the miniature black
hole of scp-123 shares these
light-bending properties but also
appears to be at least partially
observable while contained within the
outer geodesic shell while the
foundation is still unsure as to what
the outer sphere is made of it seems to
act as some sort of cage keeping the
black hole stable and secure otherwise
the cage itself along with the entire
planet outside it would presumably be
sucked into the center in fact research
staff have even been able to roughly
calculate the mass of the Interior black
sphere and have determined that the k
cage surrounding it somehow reduces the
gravitational effects of the black hole
SCP Foundation experts state that the
black hole within scp-123 currently has
a mass of approximately 10 to the 29th
power kilograms within the outer shell
but the Cage's dampening effects May
mean that the inner sphere's actual mass
could be even higher under ordinary
circumstances a black hole with a 10 to
the 29th power kilograms of mass would
have a Schwarz child radius of about 200
meters any professional astrophysicists
in our audience will already be well
aware that a Schwartz child radius is
the size of the black hole's Event
Horizon if you remember earlier we
mentioned that an event horizon is the
area that surrounds a black hole and
going past this boundary means that you
now have a one-way ticket into the black
hole whether you like it or not the fact
that scp-123 doesn't have such a large
Event Horizon and that only objects
placed within the outer sphere are
pulled in shows that the only thing
stopping the black hole absorbing
everything around it including all of us
is the cage it's currently held in
nothing can escape the pull of a black
hole no solid matter no liquids not even
light however in the case of scp-123 it
seems that there is at least one state
of matter that this black hole is unable
to absorb gases even though gases matter
is affected by the gravitational force
of scp-123 for some unknown reason gas
cannot breach the gaps in the outer
shell surrounding the black hole the SCP
Foundation is still studying why only
solids and liquids may pass through the
cage while gas cannot but it's almost
certainly for the best after all if
scp-123 could absorb gas and pull other
elements into its mass there would be
little to stop it from sucking up all
the oxygens surrounding it somehow
either by an intentional design or by
the natural properties of the material
it's crafted from the cage around the
inner sphere seems to protect the
outside world from the miniature black
hole it prevents the entire planet's air
as well as the rest of the planet itself
from being pulled in and crushed while
also keeping the black hole at a far
more manageable size the two components
of scp-123 seem to behave in a symbiotic
manner acting together as one when
someone moves the outer cage the black
hole will follow and stay in a fixed
position hovering inside the center of
the geodesic casing just what exactly
makes both of scp-123's Parts behave in
such a way has left even the
foundation's top researchers baffled
while a miniaturized black hole could
potentially cause devastating damage for
now at least
scp-123 doesn't pose much of a threat as
long as it remains contained by the SCP
Foundation within the confines of the
geodesic cage the black hole itself is
nearly harmless only pulling in small on
objects as a result the foundation has
been able to securely keep scp-123
inside one of their facilities the
contained miniature black hole is
fastened to a sturdy table with the use
of straps and chains however Personnel
are forbidden from affixing any hooks to
the gaps in the outer casing otherwise
these run the risk of being dragged into
the black hole's gravitational pull
potentially along with whatever the
hooks were attached to the foundation's
researchers monitor the black hole 24
hours a day seven days a week 52 weeks a
year devices for measuring the
gravitational force of scp-123 are
placed within the same room the black
hole is capped but at a safe distance of
100 meters away staff are also
instructed to never Place objects within
the outer shell of scp-123 and are
prohibited from inserting any objects
through the gaps in the geodesic sphere
unless an experiment is taking place at
all times
scp-123 is to be treated with the utmost
care as if it was a fragile object and
for all the foundation knows of the
unidentified outer sphere it could well
be if the cage containing the black hole
was ever breached anything within 200
meters would be pulled into the center
of scp-123 as all forms of nearby matter
were absorbed the black hole would begin
to increase in size pulling anything and
everything into itself as it continued
to grow before long the entirety of
planet Earth would be collapsing in on
itself all poured towards one single
point until the planet fractured perhaps
the scp-123 black hole would release and
then absorb enough Hawking radiation to
seal itself but by that point the world
as we know it would be gone a true XK
Class end of the world scenario with
pretty much nothing the foundation can
do to stop it once it's already started
even scp-2000 would be worthless once it
was sucked inside the miniature black
hole so when we say that scp-123 needs
to be handled with extreme care we truly
mean it the fate of the world depends on
it meaning no one member of the
foundation should ever shake the sphere
around or exert any kind of force onto
it during any transfers
scp-123 is not to be transported over
large bodies of water in case it begins
to pull the liquid into its Center
researchers working near and studying
the miniature black hole even have to
adhere to a strict dress code to avoid
their clothes getting absorbed into the
spatial anomaly any member of foundation
staff interacting with scp-123 is
instructed that they must wear
tight-fitting clothing so no straps or
laces no chains or other dangling
jewelry and long hair has to be tied
back sounds a lot like a school uniform
dress code right it might not be all
that fashionable but it's a small price
to pay to avoid getting painfully pulled
through the small triangular gaps in the
outer shell into the black hole within
the only question left is what do you do
with a tiny perpetually stable black
hole when left alone
scp-123 doesn't really seem to have much
of a purpose but it's certainly good at
getting rid of things so well that you'd
never ever see them again the contained
miniature black holes gravitational
force has led to some higher ranking
individuals in the SCP Foundation
discussing
scp-123's potentially usefulness as a
disposal unit after all nothing you'd
throw into it would ever come back
however the head researchers studying
this phenomena is concerned about the
structural Integrity of the geodesic
cage that the black hole is kept in
anyone looking to dispose of something
using scp-123 must first get this
doctor's approval to do so or request a
formal hearing with a foundation higher
up otherwise any interactions with the
miniature black hole are restricted with
experiments still ongoing to determine
how strong that outer cages and just how
long it's going to hold for because if
it ever breaks trust us you'll know what
are those things a member of the
exploration team asks pointing to
hundreds of clear orbs he begins moving
towards the mysterious objects progress
is slow the bulky space suit is meant to
withstand the planet's hostile
conditions but doesn't allow for much
maneuverability it looked like canisters
containing some sort of creature the SCP
agent says DR Sanders points his
headlamp in the direction of the voice
Mother of God he whispers into his
helmet stop moving he yells are those
eggs nothing is supposed to be able to
survive on this planet that's why it was
chosen for off-world testing and
containment for the foundation's
deadliest entities the team points their
lights at the orbs the creatures inside
don't seem to be moving they are
suspended in some type of gel and when
the light hits them the creatures look
like metallic squids doc Sanders holds
up his hand to Signal the rest of the
team to stop moving I thought I saw some
activity he says the team looks around
but they don't see anything I must be
jumping at Shadows grab the equipment
let's get out of here we need to contact
SCP command and find out what they want
us to do with these things the team
packs up their gear and makes their way
out of the Cave System beneath the alien
planet's surface as they exit the mouth
of the cave they are greeted by a
nighttime sky filled with stars in
nebula the undesignated planet is
located in the Deep recesses of space
the only light on this part of the
planet comes from the suits of Dr
Sanders's Team without any light
pollution like on Earth it seems as if
every part of the universe is visible if
it wasn't so creepy here it'd be kind of
beautiful one of the team members says
all of the SCP agents have stopped
walking and stare up at the Cosmos come
on since DR Sanders let's get back to
Elena and find out what the o5 council
wants us to do with this new discover
recovery the next night the exploration
team is back at the caverns where they
discovered the mysterious orbs the
previous evening DR Sanders leads his
team into the winding tunnel system it
leads directly under one of the largest
mountain ranges on the planet they
approached the chamber that contains the
clear orbs and get to work collecting
samples to bring back to the lab we have
no idea what these things actually are
so be careful if you see movement
immediately back away I want teams of
two for each pod one person collects a
sample the other holds the incinerator
at the ready just in case you need to
fry whatever is inside these things the
team members confirmed their orders and
get to work everything goes according to
plan the samples are gathered and the
SCP team makes its way out of the
caverns when they get to the surface DR
Sanders radios to the command center at
Elena we're out from under the mountain
canisters have been secured estimated
time to the Rover is four minutes we'll
update when in route to base Roger that
extraction team will have the loading
Bay ready for your arrival responds the
communications officer at Elena Sanders
and his crew board the Rover and put the
canisters in the storage compartment the
drive back to Elena is uneventful the
entire planet is basically made up of
dust and rocks until yesterday everyone
at Elena thought they were the only
living things out here other than the
few dangerous scps they brought along
with them to experiment on the Rover
pulls into the research base and Parks
outside the airlock the team carries the
canisters into the storage dome for
further analysis before heading to
decontamination Sanders walks out of the
airlock and takes off his helmet rain we
brought back the orbs and they're
awaiting your analysis in the storage
Bay I don't know what they are but the
fact that they might be alive will be of
great interest to the foundation I look
forward to examining the specimens we're
kind of backed up right now but we'll
get around to it you know saving the
best for last and all researcher Breen
responds there's a delicate matter that
we're attending to at the moment it
should be resolved soon Breen looks down
at the clipboard he's holding and frowns
I've got to go but I'll keep you updated
after a few days Breen calls DR Sanders
into his lab you're going to want to see
this it's those weird egg type specimens
you brought back from the caverns
they've been designated
scp-1124 perfect I've been dying to know
what these things are Sandra says as he
enters the lab do you mind if I record
this just so I have something to send
back to my superiors at the foundation
Breen agrees and the two SCP researchers
begin their analysis of the clear orbs
so they're not made of glass like we
originally thought Breen begins we
actually aren't entirely sure what these
things are made of they definitely have
the shape of an egg but the solid clear
outer layer makes me think they are more
like carrying containers than anything
else see look Brie grabs the top of one
of the orbs and pulls it off there is a
satisfying pop like a champagne cork
exploding out of the top of a bottle DR
Sanders looks at the lid and then
watches as Breen puts the top back on
the orb but that's not the way it is
part Breen says take a look at what's
inside Sanders leans over the opened orb
and looks into it the creature inside
looks like a silver squid it does not
move but Sanders gets an uneasy feeling
as if there is something inherently
dangerous and evil about the metallic
squids come over here I have some laid
out on the table for you to examine says
Brain they walk over to another lab
bench where there are several creatures
laid out Breen uses forceps to move the
appendage of one of the creatures the
limbs are segmented but there is no sign
of eyes or mouth as far as Sanders can
tell what are they ask Sanders no idea
but watch this brain picks up one of the
creatures with the forceps by the
tentacle Sanders expects the arm to be
flexible and rubbery like a squids but
instead they are stiff and rigid Like a
Knife when Breen picks up the limb the
entire creature moves with it like a
statue he pulls out a scalpel and looks
at DR Sanders watch this he says nothing
happens as Breen presses the blade
against scp-1124's exoske
he pushes harder and harder and harder
eventually the scalpel breaks and the
blade clangs to the floor we haven't
been able to break the shown so we don't
know exactly what's inside but I have a
few ideas on how to crack this puppy
open Brain says with a smile he pulls
out a blowtorch and begins blasting the
metallic squid with the flame there is
no effect Breen then brings out a vat of
liquid nitrogen he picks up one of the
creatures and places it inside the
canister when he pulls it out the
instance of scp-1124 is covered in Frost
Breen grabs a hammer off of one of the
lab tables and smashes it down onto the
shell there's a Clank as if the hammer
struck a metal pole the brain shakes his
hand which is now throbbing from the
reverberation sent through the hammer on
impact maybe they aren't alive after all
Chuckles DR Sanders maybe they're just
figurines or statues or something that's
what I was starting to think too replies
brain ah what a waste of time Sanders
says he Hawks a loogie and spits at
scp-1124 in disgust the spit hits the
outer shell and slowly begins to run
down the side DR Sanders and brain take
a seat at one of the tables and it
seemed like those things were going to
hold some real promise maybe even get us
off this rock yes the orbs and whatever
is inside of them are real Duds brain
commiserates guess it's time to focus on
suddenly one of the arms of the
creatures that DR Sanders spat on begins
to move did you see that bring yours the
squid thing it just moved its arm green
and Sanders run to the lab table where
the instance of scp-1124 slowly
stretches its tentacles as if feeling
its surroundings to get a better idea of
its location Breen reaches out to touch
one of the metallic arms stop don't
touch
DR Sanders yells but it's too late the
creature makes contact with Brian's skin
it instantly Comes Alive all of its
tentacles are now moving freely the ends
have sharpened temps the creature jerks
one of its tentacles slashing Breen's
neck blood spatters across the room
covering several other instances of
scp-1124 as the blood touches them they
slowly come to life their tentacles move
all around as if searching for the
source of the bodily fluid DR Sanders
shrieks for help he Sprints towards the
door but before he can reach it one of
the instances of scp-1124 launches
itself off of a table and impales its
spiked arms into Sanders back he screams
in pain tears fall down the sides of his
cheek as his hand slams against the
glass door that leads out of the lab the
creature climbs up his back and over his
head it then prized DR Sanders mouth
open and squirms down his throat as he
is torn apart from the inside by the
metal tentacles of scp-1124 his hand
slides down the door leaving a bloody
handprint the audio recorder continues
to run in the lab it picks up the
unsettling sounds of metal on metal and
the guttural screeches of the scp-1124
creatures the glass door leading from
the lab to the rest of the Elena
facility shatters instances of scp-1124
comes streaming out the researchers at
the base have no idea that one of the
most dangerous scps the foundation has
ever faced is now squirming along the
halls of the facility looking for hosts
to lay their eggs inside years go by
without any communication from Elena the
foundation assumes something has gone
wrong but that was the point of setting
up the base on a Faraway planet in the
first place if an experiment got out of
hand or a dangerous SCP escaped the only
people who would be in danger were the
agents and class D Personnel at Elena it
was a much safer alternative to
conducting these sorts of experiments on
Earth the o5 council redacts much of the
information on Elena and the research
happening there the file is buried deep
within the foundation state database and
forgotten that is until several years
later when a ship from Elena crashed
lands just outside an Air Force Base in
Nevada General we've just received word
from the foundation that one of our deep
space research vessels has crashed in
the desert not too far from here the o5
council has asked that we sent a team to
recover whatever is on board apparently
it came from a base called Elena never
heard of it responds to General alright
let's send a task force to go retrieve
whatever is on board that thing a group
of SCP scientists and agents are
dispatched to carry out reconnaissance
and containment procedures for the
crashed Elena rocket there is very
little information on what to expect as
most of the reports and documents about
Elena are classified as the team sets
out to recover whatever is on board the
rocket a reptile-like creature that has
remained dormant at the base for the
last 30 years Twitches no one notices
the slight movement even though this SCP
is heavily guarded and deemed one of the
biggest threats to Humanity's very
existence General we've reached the
crash site one of the agents radios back
to the air base the rocket is in rough
shape but the cargo hold seems to be
intact we're opening it now the
extraction team uses welding torches to
cut through the outer lock of the
capsule they pull back the door and peer
inside what are those things one of the
agents asks as the flashlight moves
across the cargo hold the team can see
hundreds of glassy orbs packed tightly
into the space within the rocket well
let's get them back to the base so they
can be analyzed says the team leader
using recommended containment procedures
the extraction team carefully removes
each of the orbs and loads them onto a
transport helicopter all the agents wear
a protective hazmat suits and no one is
allowed to directly come into contact
with the orbs once the helicopter is
loaded it takes off and returns to the
Air Force Base the chopper lands and a
team of researchers load the orb into a
containment pod which is then
immediately brought to the lab for
analysis I finally found some
information on what Elena was and what
these things might be a lead scientist
at the base informs the other
researchers it took a lot of digging but
I'm pretty sure the orbs are classified
as scp-1124 as far as I can tell they
contain some kind of squid-like statue
but the information from Elena is kind
of spotty not exactly sure what happened
up there the other researchers listen as
they're briefed we're pretty much
starting from scratch here so be careful
and use proper containment procedures as
if you're dealing with an unknown SCP
the lead scientist finishes the
researchers nod to indicate they've
heard what their bosses had to say and
then get to work deep underground The
Reptilian creature still lies dormant
there are slight fluctuations in the
thermal readings in its containment
chamber but the does not seem to wake
the SCP agents on duty note in their log
that the thermal sensors might need to
be recalibrated the researchers enter a
clean room and lock themselves inside
they have brought in one of the scp-1124
orbs for further analysis as the
researcher who's holding the orb walks
towards the table in the middle of the
room he accidentally trips the other
researcher reaches out and tries to grab
his colleague but misses the orb falls
to the ground the researcher scrapes his
leg on the corner of the table he
doesn't notice the tear on his
protective suit where a small trickle of
blood drips onto the floor oh that
really hurt the researcher says rubbing
his shin the orb rolls in a circle on
the ground it slowly comes to a stop
right on top of a drop of blood from the
injured researcher the orb begins to
shudder both of the scientists look in
shock as it rolls along the floor
banging into the containment chamber
walls as if it was looking for a way out
the researchers jumped to their feet and
run after the ore one of the scientists
grabbed the Orab the ground and holds it
tightly in both hands suddenly a hole
appears in the orb's surface the
researcher looks at one another Their
Eyes Wide in Terror the researcher
holding the orb puts his hand over the
hole to cover it he instantly recoils in
pain as something stabs him from within
a metallic tentacle appears through the
hole in the orb followed by a creature
with a squid-like body the creature
remains motionless sensing the room
around him the scientist not holding the
orb races towards the storage closet to
find something to cover the hole with
the other researcher remains motionless
hoping that the creature will just go
back into its container without warning
the creature launches itself at the
faceplate of the researcher holding the
ore it smashes through the protective
shielding and enters the mouth of the
researcher the other scientist screams
in Terror he runs out of the containment
chamber and slams down the button to
activate the Fail-Safe to prevent a
containment breach the room begins to
fill with mist and trifilic acid alarms
sound in the lab other SCP Personnel
come rushing in they watch him horror as
the head of the researcher with scp-1124
inside of him starts to expand blood
begins to pour out of his nose eyes and
ears then with a gruesome pop the
researcher's head explodes the
researchers lean closer to the window to
get a better look at what's happening
they scan the room when suddenly an
instance of scp-1124 slams into the
observation glass the researchers jump
back in Surprise a crack runs the length
of the observation window at the same
time the alarms are going off in the
research lab different alarms sound deep
within the facility sensors have picked
up a huge jump in thermal energy in The
Reptilian creatures chamber along with
the movement of its tail and limbs armed
SCP Foundation agents run towards the
containment chamber but when they are
only a few feet away the blast doors
forced off its hinges and slams against
the far wall of the complex the
containment team screeches to a halt as
scp-682 slowly Lumbers out of its cell
and shakes its body the creature locks
eyes with the agents who are frozen in
shock it curls back its lips to reveal
razor sharp teeth saliva falls to the
floor open fire one of the agents yells
they fire a barrage of bullets at
scp-682 but they seem to have no effect
the creature stalks towards the agents
and uses its claws and teeth to tear
them apart
scp-682 runs through the facility
killing every living thing in its path
it bursts out into the sunlight where it
sniffs the air it then Sprints towards
the high density fence and bursts
through it as if it was nothing more
than cob Labs
scp-682 runs in the direction of the
crashed Elena rocket a battalion of
Agents is deployed to stop scp-682 but
the monster quickly destroys anyone and
anything in its path it seems to be on a
mission and nothing will stop it when
scp-682 reaches the rocket it consumes
the entire research team that is there
examining the spacecraft it then began
again sniffing around the area and
climbs into the cargo hold it's looking
for something mobile task force Iota 5
approaches the rocket in two teams the
first is on the ground in armored
vehicles the second is in a helicopter
they have a plan it seems that scp-682
is looking for the orbs that were inside
the rocket for some reason they are
incredibly important to scp-682 and it
will stop at nothing to find them
scp-682 is acting like a mother
searching for a lost child mobile task
force Iota 5 has brought one of the
scp-1124 orbs with them in hopes they
can lure scp-682 back to its containment
chamber when the first team approaches
in the chopper
scp-682 stops its search the creature
sniffs the air and spots the helicopter
uh-oh I think he spotted us says the
pilot the ground force opens fire on
scp-682 the creature does not seem
interested in them in instead scp-682
remains fixated on the helicopter as if
it knows there is an orb on board the
creature leaps off the rocket and begins
running towards the helicopter the pilot
turns the chopper and flies away with
scp-682 in Pursuit they make it back to
the Air Force Base just ahead of scp-682
one of the agents jumps out of the
helicopter with the scp-1124 orb in his
hands he races towards a mobile
Containment chamber where he places the
orb at the far end before turning to get
out when he looks up scp-682 is standing
in the doorway its chest heaves up and
down its eyes are wild the SCP agent
raises his gun and fires
scp-682 snarls and leaps into the
containment chamber the whole thing
Shakes as the agent is torn apart his
gunshots and screams are silenced as the
door to the containment chamber shuts
the Fiasco known as the gray Dragon
incident is an embarrassment to the
foundation the L5 Council has everyone
involved terminated
scp-682 is secured in a new containment
facility far away from scp-1124 and the
Mysterious orbs are placed in their own
containment chamber and hidden away from
the world the working hypothesis is that
scp-1124 are the eggs of scp-682 but
further tests will need to be done and
since both of these scps are extremely
dangerous these experiments might need
to be conducted on a far away planet
Perhaps it is time for the SCP
Foundation to revisit Elena once again
let's just hope this time they don't
bring anything else back an elderly
woman watches from her living room
window as heavy Sheets of Rain Fall
outside she rocks back and forth in her
chair nervously it's been raining for
days the road is washed out I can't get
into town what am I to do what am I to
do she says out loud to herself the
rocking chair creaks under her weight
but not as much as it had three days ago
before she ran out of food I am so
hungry the old lady moans she glances at
the door that leads to her basement
maybe I can find something to eat down
there she stands up her 90 year old
bones Creak as she slowly shuffles
towards the basement door the empty
chair rocks back and forth from the old
woman's momentum as if someone is still
sitting in it she opens the door and
looks into the pitch black darkness
there are no windows down there the only
light is connected to a drawstring in
the middle of the room the old woman
slowly makes her way down the uneven
wooden steps when she reaches the bottom
she reaches out her wrinkled hand
groping in the darkness for the
drawstring her hand brushes something it
feels like sticky yarn then she feels
the legs of a spider Scurry up her arm
the old woman lets out a shriek as her
hand locates the string and she pulls
hard the light flickers on it creates a
dim glow but at least she can now see
what's in the basement the string swings
back and forth casting a snake-like
shadow on the far wall the old woman
scans the floor for anything to eat a
leftover tuna can some pickled
vegetables a rat anything we'll do at
this point there is nothing there the
old woman feels her strength has been
almost completely drained she doesn't
know how she'll make it back up the
stairs in desperation she looks around
the basement One Last Time her eyes fall
on an old rusty saw she pauses for a
moment I need to eat she Whispers The
Old Woman slowly walks towards the saw
she picks it up and examines it God gave
me two hands for a reason she says her
eyes locked on the rusty blade she
places one hand on the wooden workbench
that sits against the wall and grips the
saw tightly with the other the old one
takes a deep breath and brings the saw
down towards her hand where are we going
d-94322 asked the SCP agent driving the
car house on Hadley Hill the agent
responds wow that doesn't sound creepy
at all d-94322 says as he cranes his
neck to get a glimpse of the top of the
mountain through the SUV window why
don't we just play the quiet game until
we get there the agent says as he
focuses on the pothole-ridden back roads
of Mount Zion Georgia
d-94322 holds on tightly to the handhold
above him to keep his body from slamming
into the door every time they go over a
big bump they continue on for a few more
minutes when a rundown house comes into
view the agent pulls off the road and
stops the SUV here you go he says
handing d-94322 an earpiece what am I
supposed to do with this
d-94322 asks just stick it in your ear
the agent says with just little contempt
in his voice you don't have to be rude
about it d-94322 two replies as he grabs
the earbud and sticks it in his ear
hello testing anybody out there hello
d-94322 can you hear me says a voice in
his head ah yeah you can just call me
d94 for sure d94322 is kind of a
mouthful very well the voice from the
earbud agrees my name is Dr Andrews I
will be walking you through this test
with
scp-4173 all right doc shall we get this
party started d94 says as he steps out
of the SUV he looks up at the house that
sits atop Hadley Hill the sky is dark
and clouds race over the mountain as if
they would rather be anywhere else but
here here we go d94 starts walking up
the slippery Hill being careful not to
fall he reaches the overgrown walkway
leading up to the house and pauses is
there a problem Dr Andrews asks now just
trying to psych myself up to go into
this creepy House response D9 for what's
inside anyways that is not your concern
at the moment but if you do exactly as I
tell you you should be in and out in no
time
whatever you say Doc d94 walks down the
path reaches his hand out and grips the
cool brass knob he turns it and pushes
the door open the inside of the house
smells like mothballs and decay all
right I'm in he says good head down the
hallway and turned to your left you'll
see a door that leads to the basement
let me know when you're there d94 walks
down the hallway the old wooden floor
groans under his feet he reaches the
basement door it's slightly ajar this
place gives me the creeps rightfully so
Dr Andrews chimes in it is an old spooky
house on top of an old spooky Hill in
the middle of nowhere obviously it's
going to be creepy an old woman died
here under mysterious circumstances
around 20 years ago but you don't really
need to worry about that no ghosts here
I think you think d-94 shots as he takes
a step away from the basement door
I'm just kidding there's nothing but
harmless old scp-4173 in that house and
when has an SCP ever heard anyone right
there is a long uncomfortable pause
anyways why don't you head on downstairs
so we can get you out of there as soon
as possible yeah sure d-94 says as he
begins his descent into the darkness I
can't see anything is there a light no I
think it burnt out years ago but that's
okay I can guide you it's what I'm here
for says Dr Andrews walk towards the
East wall but watch your head the
ceiling is low in that corner you'll see
what you're looking for when you get
there d94 is silent for a moment East he
asks turn left Dr Andrew's response oh
all right why didn't you say so doc d94
turns left and walks forward after a few
feet there's a loud bang as he slams his
head into the ceiling
I told you to watch your head yeah
thanks it says d94 as he rubs the bump
forming beneath his hair this place is
even spookier than the first floor you
know that right I promise there's
nothing in that room right now that can
hurt you Dr Andrews reassures d94 wait
what do you mean right now don't worry
about it just let me know when you reach
the wall d-94 after a few seconds d94's
eyes adjust to the darkness he can just
make out the damp concrete wall in front
of him it looks as if the wall is
perspiring I'm here he says good there's
a little door maybe five feet to your
left you see it asks Dr Andrews d94
turns yeah I I see it it's closed the
door itself is not very big maybe a foot
long and a half a foot wide open it says
Dr Andrew d94 hesitates what what's in
there nothing just open it Dr Andrews
repeats himself no no way man you're
lying and I'm not opening anything until
you tell me what's on the other side of
that door Dr Andrew's size we both know
that you're going to do as I say d94322
you have no other choice unless you want
to go back to that death row cell block
where we found you d94 shakes his head
and rubs the bridge of his nose fine
fine he says Dr Andrews can hear the
squeaking of hinges through the
microphone on d94's earbud it's open now
what do you see anything
ah no there's some cobwebs and dirt but
other than that it's just dark d94
thinks for a moment why is this little
door here is this some like pet door or
something you have to be I don't know
pretty small to get in there agreed just
hang tight and let me know when you hear
something we won't keep you there for
long here's something like like what
asks d94 you'll know when you hear it
says Dr Andrews five minutes go by
without a sound then 10 15. the basement
is damp and Cold d94 theme CC's
creatures scurrying around the floor but
he doesn't say anything because
acknowledging them makes his situation
more real and a lot more scary after a
half hour of waiting in silence d94
screams what the heck was that what was
what Dr Andrews is startled out of a
Daydream by the show ounce of d94 in his
ear something just moved past the door I
definitely saw what in God's name was
that yes d94 Dr Andrews tries to remain
calm but he can barely contain his
excitement the entity in the wall is why
you're down there what do you mean you
said there wasn't anything down here I
said there was nothing down there that
could hurt you if you follow my
instructions this will continue to be
true can you hear anything asks Dr
Andrews no I can't hear it but before
d94 can finish his sentence a voice
speaks from behind the wall he can't
understand what the voice is saying at
first but as his heart begins to slow
and the blood stops thumping in his ears
d-94 can make out her words oh thank
goodness I wasn't sure you would be able
to find me what took you so long says
the voice of an old woman d94 takes a
step back from the door there's someone
on the other side of that wall he hisses
into the microphone at Dr Andrews tell
it that the road is out and you had to
find an other way up says Dr Andrews in
d94's earpiece what why just do it if
you want to get out of there d94 Dr
Andrew says a little impatiently ah the
the road is out so I had to find another
way up says d94 to the little open door
on the wall oh yes the rain washed it
out I was worried I wouldn't ever get to
see another person again being stuck up
here and all
can you see me asks the voice
um no I I can't says d94 doc what is on
the other side of that wall come over
here a little closer I I can't see you
properly either says the voice it's fine
you can get closer just don't touch the
door Dr Andrews says I really don't want
to do that it says d94 do it and you
will be that much closer to getting out
I hate you whispersd94 he slowly
approaches The Little Door and speaks
into it hello oh there you are the voice
pauses as if whoever's speaking is
examining d94 I'm sorry I can't see like
I used to all right so dark in here and
it's been so long reached through the
door and let me feel your hands where I
can tell you're really there
what d94 steps away from the door no way
am I putting my hand in there come on
now don't be rude I just want to feel
that you're there it's been so long just
just a touch the voice says a little
harsher than before
grew you lady I'm not getting my hands
anywhere near This creepy hole in the
wall it says d94 he turns around and
starts walking away from The Little Door
towards the staircase leading back to
the main level of the house before he
can put his foot on the first step d-94
hears Dr Andrew's voice screaming in his
ear stop moving look you're going to
have to do it we haven't been able to
recover anyone who refuses to do what
she asks I cannot guarantee your safety
unless you put your hand through that
door are you kidding me shouts d94
you're telling me that sweet creepy old
lady will somehow kill me if I don't do
what she asks we're not entirely sure
what happens but you need to put your
hand through that door if you want to
get out of there says Dr Andrews d-94
turns back toward the little door and
slowly approaches it this is my
nightmare he says more to himself than
anyone else he reaches out slowly and
puts his fingers through the doorway he
immediately pulls them back and steps
away from the door ah I I really don't
want to do this d94 Whispers he steps
forward again and sticks his hand all
the way through the doorway for a moment
nothing happens ah all right I've got my
hand in there now what oh I can chew now
you're right there thank you for coming
oh it's been so long since someone came
and with a gift as well oh sweet ling
you're so kind so kind to me gift
what gift d94 asks nervously it's so
dark and Lonesome and I've just been so
hungry for such a long time thank you
sweetling I'll take your gift from you
you are such a rude little brat you
don't really deserve it you've had it
for too long and you don't deserve it
it's mine now mine for my belly thank
you what are you talking about you
psycho d94 stutters suddenly something
grabs his hand and pulls him against the
wall he screams in agony as Dr Andrews
hears a wet ripping sound coming through
the microphone it sounds as if some type
of metal instrument is cutting through
flesh oh God no help me help me d94
screams please please please Dr Andrews
hears the sound of d94's body hitting
the floor as he passes out it's quiet
for a moment don't worry you ungrateful
child don't worry I'll fill you up too
you can have mine I'll give it to you
sweet boy good boy fill you up says the
old woman's voice from the other side of
the wall Dr Andrews listens as the
hinges of The Little Door squeak can it
click shut he picks up the phone next to
him and does it go in and get him bring
him back to site 94 for observation and
try to keep this one alive please he
hangs up the phone and prepares the lab
for d-94322 to be brought in d-94 slowly
comes out of his medically induced coma
two days after the incident with
scp-4173 he's stable but doesn't feel
great and he can't help but sense that
something is different d94 looks at
where his hand should be there's nothing
there that crazy old lady ate my hand he
starts screaming the medical team rushes
in as red lights begin to flash and
Sirens Blair they attempt to restrain
d94 during the struggle d94 catches a
glimpse of himself in a mirror on the
far side of the room he stops fighting
for a moment there is a growth expanding
from his head what the heck is that he
yells pointing to his reflection d94
begins to struggle again this time much
more intensely he begins scratching at
the growth on the side of his head
without much success in the process he
pushes the growth further into his skull
it penetrates his brain d-94 blacks out
the medical team ties d-94 to the bed
and tries to get a reading on his vitals
the growth is putting too much pressure
on his brain they Rush him to the ER but
d-94322 dies before he reaches the
operating table Dr Andrew stands over
the body of the deceased class D subject
cut him open he says to the doctor
standing in the room one of them pulls
out a scalpel and makes an incision into
the side of d94's head what is that one
of the doctors says the other bends over
to get a better look after a moment he
turns away and vomits into his face mask
Dr Andrews picks up a pair of forceps
off the table he sticks them deep into
the hole in the side of d94's head and
clamps down hard Dr Andrew pulls out a
decomposing hand the fingers are still
moving as if trying to grab onto
something there's no explanation for how
it got in there but it is obvious that
scp-4173 played some sort of role in the
phenomenon Dr Andrews goes back into his
office to review previous Case Files on
scp-4173 everyone who had put their hand
into the small doorway has been pulled
towards the wall and had their hand
chopped off the severed appendage never
ends up being a clean cut which leads Dr
Andrews to hypothesize the gruesome
makeshift operation is done with some
sort of tool with teeth once the hand of
the victim is severed
scp-4173 always thanks the person for
their gift she then informs them not to
worry about their hand as it will be
replaced but then something incredibly
strange happens like with d94 a decaying
hand will appear somewhere in the body
but it isn't always inside the head in
fact depending on how polite the test
subject is to the old one woman behind
the door the closer to the wrist the
decaying hand actually ends up for the
test subjects who are rude to the old
lady the decaying hand ends up in some
pretty interesting places she really
hated d-94322 Chuckles Dr Andrews to
himself Dr Andrews continues flipping to
the back of the file on
scp-4173 the SCP Foundation doesn't
quite know how it happens but people who
refuse to offer their hand to scp-4173
suffer a worse fate than those who
surrender to the old lady in every case
where a subject tries to get away from
the small door some inexplicable Force
seems to grab them from behind and drag
them through the tiny opening in these
cases there is nothing left of the test
subject it is likely fatal as a human is
much smaller than the opening itself so
the only way a body could fit through
the doorway is if every bone is broken
and every muscle compressed to a quarter
of its actual size I'm not sure which is
worse Dr Andrews says aloud as he closes
the file on
scp-4173 he glances at the picture paper
clip to the front of the manila folder
depicting the tiny doorway he can't
quite pinpoint why but the fact that the
door slowly closes after the old woman
gets what she needs from her victims
sends chills down his spine the words of
the old woman echo in his head don't
worry I'll fill you up too you can have
mine I'll give it to you sweet boy good
boy fill you up Russell's Back was
pressed against the wall his shuddering
hands gripping the fire ax the low
emergency lighting filling the corridor
indicated the lockdown was still in
effect although that was simultaneously
a blessing and a curse sure it meant
that thing couldn't get out hopefully
but it also meant that Russell was stuck
in the wing of the facility with it he
had no idea if anyone else was left he
hadn't seen what had happened to
Carpenter maybe it got him or perhaps he
had managed to give it the slip at the
last second there was no way of knowing
for sure it had all started so simply so
innocently and with such Noble
intentions if he had known it would lead
to all this madness Russell would have
never put his name down on the request
form the SCP Foundation had been working
on a way to neutralize or cure scp-610
for what felt like forever to one team
of scientists the infamously so-called
flesh that hates was a fascinating
organism it was a highly contagious
sarcic skin disease isolated entirely
within the small area of Siberia that on
its own wasn't enough to Peak the
interest of the research team led by Dr
Carpenter including his hand-picked star
researchers Russell and David along with
their assistant clennan and Dr bottin an
expert on infectious diseases who had
recently joined their efforts to provide
his specialist knowledge what did
Captivate all of them however was what
scp-610 did when it infected a human
being the disease would trigger
aggressive and uncontrollable mutations
within its infected and could virtually
rewrite their entire physiology in a
heartbeat the flesh that hates was
capable of transforming a person's body
into a horrifying fleshy mass of Limbs
and matter that barely resemble the
human being anymore and in addition the
infected individuals would retain some
level of awareness attacking any
uninfected person with extreme hostility
there had long been chatter amongst some
other research teams studying scp-610
about devising a way to weaponize the
disease if they could somehow create a
variant that didn't turn people into
monsters or at least caused the fleshy
Abominations to die shortly after
mutation then the foundation or another
interested party could deploy the flesh
that hates as a biological weapon Dr
Carpenter had long abhorred the idea
instead searching for a way to
completely reverse the effects of an
scp-610 infection it may have been
idealistic perhaps even naive by some
standards but the rest of his team was
behind him in the pursuit of that Noble
goal although not one of them knew it
would soon cost them their lives hitting
speed bump after speed bump in their
research the team were beginning to lose
hope researcher David was the most
outspoken in how tired he was of seeing
the same results yelling in frustration
that the flesh could not be cured by
conventional means however it was that
Outburst that gave Russell the idea they
had tried trading scp-610 like a common
virus as if it was any other form of
disease largely thanks to Dr button's
input and granted that approach had
taught them a lot about the flesh's
ability to contaminate a subject from a
single cell but this infection was
anomalous through and through could the
solution to eradicating it for good lie
not in a medical cure but in another SCP
Russell brought this hypothesis to the
rest of the research team and each of
them had suggestions for other anomalies
they could potentially use to cure a
subject of the flesh that hates we could
get scp-049 to take a look at the
infected patient clenin suggested well
it might work Carpenter amused although
even if he cares someone he might also
kill them he has his whole deal about
ridding the world of the pestilence
could prove to be a problem there's
always 682 David said dryly have the
reptile eat up all the scp-610
infectives and voila problem solved oh
real helpful David researcher Russell
retorted and what are we gonna do when
scp-682 adapts to the flesh you really
want an infected Immortal lizard on the
loose Gentlemen please Dr Button spoke
up we're forgetting one obvious option I
propose we submit a joint formal request
to use scp-914 for this experiment
unanimously the group all agreed that
this was the best course of action
scp-914 or the Clockworks was a giant
machine with two boots marked input and
output although the foundation still
couldn't fully comprehend exactly how as
cp914 seemed to take any object placed
within it and disassemble recreate
improve or destroy the item depending on
its current setting there was one issue
however a prior failed experiment where
in a d-class was placed in scp-914 had
led to some pretty disastrous
consequences as a result ever since no
organic matter was to be placed within
the Clockworks rule that the teams
experiment with the flesh would breach
still they pressed on each of the five
researchers signing their request to
utilize scp-914 before it was submitted
to the foundation higher-ups within
hours the request was denied but the
team was determined that scp-914 could
be the key to solving the foundation's
long-standing issue with scp-610 Dr
Carpenter repealed the decision
urging the higher-ups to reconsider he
argued that this flouting of the no
organic matter rule was necessary to
potentially rid the world of the flesh
that hates after a few days of
consideration the request was finally
Faithfully granted the team went to work
immediately requisitioning two test
subjects both of which had suffered
scp-610 infections and were horribly
mutated the pair of them were deemed a
potential Hazard to every member of
foundation staff on site and as a result
the entire wing of the facility where
the clock works with house had to be
evacuated for safety dressed in
biohazard suits to protect themselves
the researchers used an electric cattle
prod to coax the first flesh specimen
into the input chamber of scp-914 this
was the test run they wanted to see if
the Clockworks would actually be able to
affect those infected with scp-610 at
all plus they needed a Fail-Safe just in
case something went wrong and luckily
the machine had just the thing Russell
asked Clemen to set the Clockworks to
rough and with a click in War of its
numerous gears and Gyros
scp-914 came to life instantly the
infected test subject was completely
obliterated the setting had reduced it
to atoms disintegrating it on such a
microscopic level that there was nothing
left in the output chamber the second
infected creature seemed to bristle with
anger but didn't attack or become
aggressive as it too was plotted towards
the Clockworks next perhaps out of fear
that their Theory might be wrong the
team agreed to set scp-914 to its
one-to-one setting sure enough the
machine recreated another instance of a
specimen infected with the flesh that
hates replacing the previous one we all
know we're stalling researcher David
piped up let's do what we came here for
set the Clockworks to coarse nervously
receding a nod from Dr Carpenter Lennon
stepped forward to switch the dial on
scp-914 to the course setting this was
the primary reason the team had all
agreed to use the machine on a flesh
specimen this setting could disassemble
any item placed in the input Booth
separating it into its base components
botton had suggested the use of scp-914
based on the theory that if it worked
correctly the Clockworks could extract
the flesh that hates from its infected
host rendering them free of the disease
the machine made a colossal amount of
noise as clennan hurried back to a safe
distance with the others but as it was
powering up seconds from activating Dr
Carpenter noticed something the color
drained from his face as he saw it none
of the others had noticed from a
distance that the style hadn't been set
to course instead it pointed to very
fine the highest refinement setting 914
had what the hell have you done
Carpenter yelled at clennan before the
machine suddenly activated would step
free from the output Booth stunned the
researcher it was a man a seemingly
ordinary human who had presumably been
infected by scp-610 some time ago he
stepped nervously out of the machine
looking confused for a moment as a para
Foundation security guards cautiously
approached him we did it Russell said in
awe suddenly fleshy tendrils burst forth
from the man's arms latching on to the
approaching guards they screamed in
agony their bodies melting become a
bloody misshapen mass that stayed
attached to the humanoid creature at the
center it was like they became a part of
it the guards arms and legs forming
additional limbs as their forms were
reconstituted and repurposed as part of
a monster that was now crawling on its
six legs towards the research team in a
blind
the group scrambled for the entrance the
head of the infected man splitting open
down the middle opening up into a wide
snapping pair of Jaws panting hard as he
ran his breath fogging up the clear
faceplate of The Biohazard suit Russell
ran through the door hearing someone
close behind he stopped for a moment
looking back to see the creature on the
other side of the door starting to spill
through the door frame like a liquid
running faster around a corner Russell
came to another halt in the common area
a third security guard following just
before a thick Steel security door came
slamming down sealing the creature on
the other side the other door didn't
hold it what good is that going to do
researcher David yelled more to the
point Dr Carpenter said turning and
marching towards Glennon he launched a
furious punch at the assistant knocking
him to the floor why did you set 9 14 to
very fine clenin the enraged doctor
shouted you're the one who Unleashed
that Abomination you maniac what Glennon
replied fearfully trembling I I didn't I
so of course I'm sure of it you expect
us to believe that was a mistake
gentlemen we need to focus on the
situation at hand the security officer
interjected regardless of who's
responsible we need to inform the
foundation higher-ups there's an
emergency lockdown Russell replied it
would have triggered the moment the
scp-610 specimen got free you've trapped
us with a monster clenin Dr Carpenter
spat hold on researcher David spoke up
wasn't it button's idea to use 914 in
the first place the common area felt
silent as everyone turned to look at Dr
botton did you plan for this doc David
push Von chuckled need I remind you my
friends that we all agreed to use the
Clockworks did we not all of our names
are on the request he answered besides
accusing me David that's rather Rich
coming from you what's that supposed to
mean the researcher fired back beckoning
his finger botton encouraged the rest of
the team to follow him across the common
area to wear a row of lockers stood each
door bearing one of their names he
gestured to the one labeled David go on
button added shooting him a dirty look
David Barnes passed the disease expert
and opened his locker not one among the
group expected what would fall out it
was an old leather-bound book symbols
carved into the front cover instantly
thanks to the work studying scp-610 the
researchers all knew a text on sarcasism
when they saw one it had been long known
that the flesh that hates was often
described in text revered by sarkic
Cults who worshiped death Decay and
disease what the hell David Russell
exclaimed picking up the book and
examining it in disbelief you're a
sarkist carpenter asked the fury in his
voice already elevating no I'm not
researcher David protested I've never
seen that before it was in your locker
the doctor yelled you're one of those
cannibal cultists this was your plan to
refine the flesh from your Twisted death
worshiping religion it certainly seems
that way button interjected after all
researcher David did seem frustrated at
our earlier results impatient even
you David pointed at the doctor you
planted this in my locker you're here a
sarcast clennan repeated in a nervous
stammer you made me turn the dial to
very fine you made that thing appear you
made me your accomplice anger tears
streamed on his face Clement's hand
reached for the security officer's gun
and went to draw it planning to shoot
David on the spot but as he went to pull
the weapon from the guard's holster it
wouldn't budge it was then that
assisting clenan stared in horror at his
hand his fingers had fused to the
guard's leg the officer gave a twisted
grin as his torso burst open tendrils of
Flesh latching onto clenin and
assimilating him just like it had done
before the flesh creature broke down its
victim's body making it a new part of
itself a grotesque mass of Limbs and
bloody matter littered with the
discarded faces of those it had infected
the research team looked at it terrified
their stomach's turning disgusted at the
growing growling abomination of bodies
fused to one another oh you're beautiful
Russell heard of voice whisper behind
him he turned to see Bonton looking at
the scp-610 creature and smiling
researcher David was the closest and the
creature lunged at him pulling his leg
out from under him screaming in fear the
researcher fell onto the ground and was
dragged towards the flesh had pulled him
in his body stretching his skin tearing
and Bones snapping as he became part of
it a new set of Limbs added to the
monster Dr Carpenter went to try and
pull him free but it was already too
late but he stepped back knowing that if
he touched it he would be infected too
the sound of running caught Russell's
attention and he spotted botton making a
break for it grabbing Dr Carpenter by
the sleeve the researcher pulled him in
the same direction partly running away
from the flesh as it assimilated David
and partly Chasing The sarkic Saboteur
the pair of them quickly caught up to
botton leaning over himself and panting
breathlessly thank God you two made it
he wheezed after the run I can't believe
David could do this to unleash this
nightmare upon us Russell thought to
snap at him to scream how dare he keep
lying but Bottom's back was to him now
he'd never get a better chance there was
a cabinet on the corridor wall
containing a fire ax for emergencies as
carefully and quietly as he could
Russell fished the ax out of its case
while Spartan and carpenter were looking
away we should get the foundation to
lift the lockdown Bond was saying they
need to let us out and then oh
he let out a blood curdling scream
mid-sentence as the ax blade wounded him
Russell pulled it back standing over the
doctor as he fell to the floor in agony
Russell have you lost your mind
Carpenter exclaimed no doctor he's the
cultist I have no idea how he tricked
Clinton but that flesh creature exists
because of him the researcher answered
from the floor unable to move thanks to
his injury Dr botton began to laugh it
took me years to infiltrate the
foundation so much time waiting to gain
access to that blessed flesh he gluded
and now you've helped me to refine it to
create its ultimate
you want to kill me go ahead Russell my
life doesn't matter for once that
creature is free it will bring about a
new age of Flesh and Grand consist iron
will reward me for the role I played in
unleashing it David was right Carpenter
realized button you you've planted that
book on him to throw us off doctor we
need to think of something researcher
Russell interjected ax still in hand
nobody knows more about the flesh that
hates than us there must be a way to
kill that thing otherwise if it gets out
of this lockdown it could spread to
everyone in the foundation what about
fire that's been effective against 610
infectives before right yes yes but the
doctor desperately tried to think this
new being we've created she created
Russell argued looking at the grimacing
wounded button we cannot deny the role
we've all played in this researcher
Carpenter argued and we have no idea if
it possesses the same weaknesses as the
flesh before its refinement but we have
to try sir the researcher protested of
course I agree the sickening sound of a
slithering slick Mass was rapidly
approaching still laying on the floor in
pain Dr botton had been dragged to the
middle of a junction with Carpenter and
Russell hiding around either Corner
suddenly botton started hollering as the
flesh came into view practically calling
it to him oh look at you he exclaimed
you're better than I could have ever
hoped for looking down at him with the
faces it had collected the creature
stabbed one of its disgusting appendages
through botton drawing its body into its
growing form I am honored to give my
life so that the age of Flesh May begin
the doctor said weekly through the pain
as he was infected from around the
corner Carpenter had taken the sarkic
text and set its pages on fire with a
cigarette lighter turning to the
creature he hurled the massive burning
paper at it hoping it would be enough
fire to spread to the flesh while it was
assimilating bottom who they had left
there as bait the fiery book collided
with the monstrosity as Russell peeked
around the corner he saw the flesh
retreating from the Flames Bond's body
now added to it for a moment it seemed
like the creature was afraid of the fire
but slowly it drew nearer and nearer to
the book with ease it stamped down the
Flames with button's leg dowsing the
fire and suffering no damage to it at
all gripping the accent his hands
Russell went to charge the creature only
to feel something push him back Dr
Carpenter had stopped him run he yelled
instantly Russell turned and raced down
the corridor the sound of fleshy
tentacles whipping through the air he
dared not looked back just in case the
monster was right behind him eventually
he reached another corner and slammed
his back against it hand shuddering as
he held onto the fire ax he had no idea
what had happened to Carpenter maybe it
got him or perhaps he had managed to
give it the slip at the last second
Russell came a hush voice from around
the corner one the researcher recognized
he turned to see Dr Carpenter
approaching him sneaking like he was
trying to avoid being heard I think I
managed to give it the slip doctor
whispered for a second Russell backed up
his hands tightening around the ax
handle this might have looked like Dr
Carpenter but was it are you really you
doctor he asked of course I am Carpenter
replied you don't think that I'm not
that monstrosity Russell raised the ax
defensively only to notice the sadness
and the doctor's face unable to bring
himself to swing even to find out the
researcher lowered his weapon Carpenter
looked grateful come on let's get them
to lift this lockdown he said I'm sure
an MTF can step in and take care of our
mistake as the pair of them cautiously
made their way towards one of the locked
doors Dr Carpenter reached out a hand to
place it on Russell's shoulder we've all
thought about disasters imagine massive
floods fires or a meteor suddenly
crashing into Earth but what happens
when the destruction comes quietly and
suddenly with the dawning of a new day
over the next 24 hours the world as we
know it will crumble and something
strange and terrible will rise to take
its place what will that look like who
will try to rise to the occasion and
help and who will cower in the dark what
happens to the people around the world
in the first 24 hours after day breaks
let's find out hour one it's 6 a.m on a
farm in chances and the land is just
beginning to wake up the farmer and his
wife and children are still sleeping
waiting for the Cry of their rooster to
tell them that it's time to start the
day the cows are grazing in the open
field letting out the occasional
half-hearted moo but they're still a bit
too sleepy to give it their all the pigs
snort restlessly in the barn feeling
breakfast time approaching the rooster
proud and stately hops onto the roof of
the chicken coop surveying his domain he
tilts his head back and lets out a
mighty Crow Cock-A-Doodle the sound
catches in his throat as something
strange begins to happen his beak
softens like Wax dripping from a lit
candle it drops to the ground with a
soft plot as his mighty wake-up call
Fades to a gurgle there is something
wrong this morning something truly
deeply wrong if the rooster were capable
of complex thought he would be terrified
instead he is just melting along with
the hens the cows and the pig
all dripping onto the grass as the faint
light of mourning changes them inside
The Farmhouse the family begins to
scream hour two an hour later in New
York City the city that never sleeps
gets a rude awakening no one can be sure
when exactly the chaos broke out but all
of a sudden people in their little
apartments wake up to the sound of
masses of other people calling out for
help of the thunderous footsteps of
crowds tearing through the streets and
then of a strange gurgling sound that
replaces the Bedlam a young woman throws
open her blackout curtains to get a
better look and finds herself melting
along with them across town a landlord
knocks on his tenant's door demanding
some overdue rent but there is no answer
only the slop of something oozing across
the floor inside security footage of
Times Square catches an eerie sight
masses of molten flesh spreading across
the streets the masses of tourists that
were gathered there only hours before
melted together into something else
bathed in the neon glow of the
Billboards and lights of the city hour
three on the other side of the world in
Canberra Australia a group of college
students is camping in the wilderness
while the United States is waking up to
a horror show they are sleeping soundly
in their tents beneath the light of the
Moon well except for one of them wood
decided to take his sleeping bag outside
and sleep under the stars that would
have been a lovely idea except for the
fact that all sunlight including that
which reflected off the moon has become
quite destructive to the human body to
all living things in fact his melted
form sloshes around inside the sleeping
bag trying to regain some semblance of
its original shape inside their tent his
friends are still themselves shielded
remarkably well from the light by the
thick canvas that is until one of them
gets up to go to the bathroom and unzips
the front of the tent his mouth is
already useless by the time he thinks to
scream and the Moonlight floods inside
and covers the group in a silvery glow
it doesn't take long for them to meet
the same fate as their friend outside
melting together into one massive entity
they had hoped this camping trip would
bring them closer together and well it
did our four meanwhile a speleologist is
deep in the bowels of a cave in chian
Chang that she has been studying
completely unaware of the Terrors of the
surface she's taking samples dictating
notes to her research assistant and
keeping an eye out for bats when
suddenly she receives a communication
from one of the members of her research
team up above the technology they use
only allows for short text messages that
can be transmitted through the layers of
soil and rock all around but this
warning needs only a few words don't
come up not safe the words send a chill
up upper spine what could possibly be
happening that's more dangerous than
being down here she writes back asking
for clarification but receives none
through the dark tunnels illuminated
only by a few headlamps she thinks she
can hear the echo of a scream hour five
those that are still safe and have
managed to hold on to their identities
and forms have noticed yet another
threat in addition to whatever the light
is doing all around the world planes are
dropping from the sky their pilots and
Crews transformed into something
incapable of flying an aircraft
airplanes that were in route to their
various destinations thousands of them
going in every direction imaginable are
now plummeting towards the ground
crashing into the ocean or in some
especially unlucky cases landing on
buildings that still have survivors
inside it's a truly brutal bit of irony
to escape the sun's terrible rays and
find some small sanctuary only to have
an airplane fall out of the sky and
destroy it all hour six over at the SCP
Foundation everyone is on high alert
trying to categorize what is happening
and find a way to stop it but how do you
contain an anomaly when that anomaly is
the sun itself in the meantime the o5
council retreats to a specialized
underground bunker constructed
especially for this kind of dire
scenario outfitted with beds reading
materials and enough supplies to keep
them alive for several years as long as
no one Hogs the snacks as the rest of
the foundation staff scrambled to find a
solution before the rest of the Earth's
population is reduced to goo the
anomalies contained throughout the
various sites begin to take notice
scp-999 oozes frantically around its
sight hugging and nuzzling anyone it can
get close to it doesn't fully understand
what is going on but it can tell that
everyone is quite upset and frightened
by something and it wants to help them
feel better other anomalies have a less
charitable approach
SCP-173 takes advantage of the chaos to
escape containment snapping a few necks
on its way out just for fun after all
everyone's eyes are otherwise occupied
because it is not made from any organic
material it is immune to the effects of
the Sun and makes its way outside to
explore the pandemonium research staff
pass by
scp-682's containment chamber can hear
the giant Beast chuckling to itself a
sickening choking sound as it laughs at
the fall of humanity finally its size
one scientist peeking through the
observation window swears that the hard
to destroy reptile is smiling before one
of his colleagues ushers him down the
hall away from the monster's celebration
scp-507 appears in the hall with a pop
back from another one of his involuntary
interdimensional voyages whoa where's
the fire he asks taking in the hysteria
around him it did something get out a
bit of unease creeps into his voice no
shots a passing guard it's what's trying
to get in god I have the worst timing
507 groans hour seven back in the realm
of civilians newscasters hop on to
broadcast from Studios devoid of natural
light unsure if there are any survivors
left to hear their messages one
television personality forces his usual
Bright Smile staring down the barrel of
the camera with barely concealed tears
in his eyes he can't let his smile crack
can't let himself break down if he lets
himself cry really Cry he's scared he
won't be able to stop please remain calm
he reads off the teleprompter as a
production assistant sobs into the
shoulder of the camera operator experts
are working to determine what is going
on in the meantime please follow these
instructions to ensure your safety and
that of your loved ones
do not go outside unless you are covered
in proper equipment to Shield yourself
from the sun or moon block all sources
of natural light in your residence do
not attempt to interact with those who
have been affected by this disaster do
not touch them to not let them into your
home do not speak to them again please
remain calm help is on the way he
doesn't know if the words are true he
only knows that it's his responsibility
to give the people hope something
familiar they can turn to when nothing
makes sense the camera switches off he
covers his face and lets the tears loose
hour eight in spite of the pleas from
newscasters people are very much
panicking how could they not
everything's descended into absolute
Mayhem and it's only been eight hours
since it All Began unfortunately where
there is panic there's someone trying to
make a quick Buck off of their fellow
man even more unfortunately the internet
is still up and running so far and with
survivors taking to social media to live
tweet their experiences and post as much
as they can on Instagram Facebook and
anywhere else they can reach out for
help it is the perfect environment for
scammers a Twitter thread goes viral
claiming that wrapping oneself in
aluminum foil will protect against the
effects of the light Facebook posts
circulate Hawking all sorts of natural
remedies and super sunscreens from
essential oil blends to bacon grease a
fraudulent GoFundMe page pops up
claiming to belong to a climate
scientist raising money for a ray gun
that will reverse the Damage Done to the
Earth's atmosphere which he cites as the
cause of the destruction hour nine not
all the information circulating online
is false however a video is posted on
Tick Tock with the caption these mofos
can talk featuring video of a teenage
boy cowering in a dark room as one of
the formerly human flesh creatures moves
around outside the door after a moment
or two of Silence a garbled voice calls
out to him bro Ryan come outside
please come out into the sun
I miss you the video's comments are
filled with other users sharing similar
experiences saying it talked just like
my boyfriend it barked like a dog or
even it was singing my favorite Ariana
Grande song similar videos pop up in the
wake of this first recording urging
survivors to ignore the voices no matter
who they seem like they belong to our
ten while some people are using the
internet to spread helpful information
on the nature of the events outside
others have ruled out rational
explanations entirely claiming that this
is divine punishment for the sins of
mankind or the Matrix finally collapsing
in on itself others deny that the
horrible events are even happening at
all an infamously contrarian live stream
personality logs on from his insulated
basement crowing to his viewers that
none of this is actually happening it's
all deploy to keep us complacent and
under government control ask yourself
why don't they want us going outside so
we don't see what they're really up to
as commenters try desperately to change
his mind he doubles down you're all just
a bunch of sheep oh papa he laughs look
I'll show you there's nothing to worry
about he carries his laptop upstairs
with him and steps outside onto the
sidewalk in his computer screen he can
see the video feed of his own face
beginning to droop and liquefy before he
can even feel it he tries to run back
inside away from the light but it's too
late his legs are already giving out the
viewers can only watch as their favorite
streamer dissolves in real time until
his now useless hands drop the laptop to
the ground where it breaks into pieces
and the stream goes Dark Hour 12. for
those who have survived this long at the
12-hour Mark things are beginning to get
tense actually that would be an
understatement tensions have been
bubbling steadily for the past 12 hours
as people have melted into
unrecognizable waxy monsters exploded in
plane crashes and been traumatized to
within an inch of their lives now those
tensions are boiling over human beings
in a crisis can be a bit like crabs in a
bucket vicious and ready to tear each
other to pieces if they perceive that
they might be left behind when there is
a shortage of resources this selfish
fear and anger only gets worse hour 13.
there might not be a lack of food or
fresh water yet but there is another
resource that seems worth destroying
each other for darkness in a world where
light means death the only safe place is
in the dark but there are a limited
number of places that people can go in
rural areas families Retreat to storm
sellers or the insides of empty grain
silos in cities underground parking
garages become hiding places and there
just isn't enough space there to go
around people erupt into physical fights
in these parking complexes punching and
shoving each other even attacking with
broken bottles and other improvised
weapons all to stake their claim over
this newfound territory even more
contentious are warehouses insulated
hiding places filled with all the
supplies that will soon start to dwindle
toilet paper canned goods soap and
bottled water these things just might be
worth killing for and many are already
prepared to do so our 14 while the SCP
Foundation is busy trying to maintain
order and find a way to end this
catastrophic event other groups
dedicated to the anomalous are equally
busy the chaos Insurgency attempt to
launch a sneak attack on site 19 while
its occupants are distracted however
their defenses against the sun prove
ineffective and they are melted before
they can so much as reach the site's
entrance inside the foundation staff
never even notice they have far too much
on their hands already other groups take
a less offensive approach prioritizing
safety members of of the Serpent's hand
escaped to The interdimensional
Wanderers Library along with their
families settling in for the Long Haul
and preparing to make it their permanent
home as the Earth Burns they didn't want
it to end this way but they are not
going to stick around to be a part of it
all hour 18. not all people are turning
on each other even as things appear dire
the best thing anyone can do in a
horrible situation is to look for those
willing to extend a helping hand there
will always be people trying to look out
for others to put out the fires and
airlift people out of the flood waters
though this disaster seems anything but
natural the instinct to health is still
there for many doctors and nurses hole
up in hospitals blocking out the windows
with spare pairs of Scrubs and whatever
else they can find to light proof the
building there they treat the wounded
that make it inside wrapping broken
bones and stitching up wounds as best
they can a few well-intentioned Souls
even attempt to treat those Changed by
the sun though things that barely look
human anymore no matter how hard they
try to arrange their soft bodies back
into their former shape it is too late
for them though there's nothing to be
done and no medical school in the world
could have prepared a doctor to heal
this hurt but what about the people who
aren't all the way gone the ones who
started to change but got inside in time
to slow or even stop the process
hospital staff treat the melting like an
infection amputating molten limbs or
attempting to clean and bandage them
unsure of what to do with a piece of
human body that no longer behaves like
flesh and Bone they're able to save a
few people but far more are already
doomed by the time they make it inside
they disintegrate slowly but steadily
fading away on the operating table until
their warbling voices are urging the
doctors to follow them outside it
doesn't hurt they promise reaching out
with fleshy tentacles that were one's
hands it's hard to remember the
Hippocratic Oath when a monster is
trying to pull you into its grasp hour
20 while some are trying to help the
creatures created by the sun's wrath
others have been waiting for this moment
since they saw their very first zombie
movie to them this is an outbreak plain
and simple and it's the perfect chance
to suit up and play Soldier they cloaked
themselves in body armor and helmets
with dark tinted visors and grab
whatever weapons they can find grenades
Firearms flamethrowers anything is fair
game at the end of the world a former
police officer and massive fan of zombie
themed first-person shooters takes to
the streets staring down an enormous
mound of flesh made from dozens of
people melting together ropey tentacles
flailing and grasping for more bodies to
add to its mass he fires an array of
bullets into the thing but they are
absorbed into its surface swallowed up
inside he searches for weak points for
eyes a heart anything he can Target but
he can't spot anything vulnerable but
he's not heard he'll try fire next he
lights a homemade Molotov cocktail and
hurls it at the Beast waiting for it to
ignite and listening for the sound of
its painful cries but nothing comes the
cocktail explodes and nearby debris
catches on fire for the ball of Flesh
doesn't react it just continues to
advance towards him making its way down
the street as if it has all the time in
the world there's only one option left
and it's the riskiest one of all he
pulls out a grenade and pulls the pin
throwing it won't do he needs to run up
and thrust the grenade into the body of
the monster to blow it up from the
inside he's going to have to be quick he
summons all the stamina from his high
school track and field days and makes a
mad Sprint for the creature holding the
grenade out in front of him eyes on the
prize there is nothing but the mission
now the chance to be a hero he is so
singularly focused on his task that he
doesn't notice a tentacle snaking along
the ground toward him until it loops
around his feet flipping him over until
he's upside
the force of the movement knocks his
helmet loose and it falls to the ground
he moves to Shield his face with his
hands but it's useless the sunlight has
already found him he is already changing
becoming one with the very thing he
promised to destroy he stares up at the
mass with reverence just before his eyes
drop out of his head and reaches his
arms out to welcome the Embrace by the
time the grenade detonates he can't
bring himself to care about it he can't
care about anything except being part of
the flesh hour 22 if individuals have a
tendency to blame each other in times of
strife then governments are even worse
surviving leaders of various countries
shivering in their bunkers and tearing
out their hair with stress begin to
convince themselves that this must be
some kind of Act of biological warfare
gone wrong nuclear testing some kind of
deadly gas something surely ruination on
this Grand of a scale must be man-made
with no other recourse they begin
declaring war on each other ever
everyone pointing a finger at someone
else as no one is able to take
responsibility the threats the denials
and the rage escalate until finally the
North Korean government makes a decision
that would seem completely insane under
any other circumstances they attempt to
Nuke the sun it's irrational and it's
ineffective of course but it's the last
gasp of a species hurtling towards
Extinction one final attempt to bring it
all to an end before it's all truly over
hour 24 and as the dust clears it
becomes completely apparent the old
world is dead and a new world For Better
or For much much worse is born nothing
will ever be the same again sirens
blared and the loud ringing of the
emergency alarm system gave everyone a
scare like something had jumped out at
them unexpectedly with that fright came
a sharp jolt of adrenaline something was
and their options were either to await
instructions or try and flee with their
lives most took the latter dropping
their shovels and various mining tools
so they could turn heal and bolt to the
nearest opening outside if they could
just get outside above ground where the
air was a little clearer than they could
avoid whatever it was that was happening
but for Yuri Escape wasn't an option he
something it had been a standard
operation everything had been run by the
books and was going all the smoother for
it but that Noble approach hadn't
stopped the drill from breaching into a
cavern carving through Stone into a
previously undiscovered area that on its
own wasn't enough to cause concern it
was the sudden cave-in that had
triggered the alarms and led to the
ensuing panic at the controls of the
gigantic excavation machine Yuri
helplessly pulled at levers and press
buttons desperately trying to undo the
rapidly worsening damage but it was too
late rocks and debris were showering
from above like the Earth itself was
retaliating against the mining workers
it was as if they shouldn't have drilled
that deep the cave in almost like they
had awakened something unfortunately for
Yuri a falling slab of stone made sure
he wouldn't get to see exactly what the
dust settled shortly after but only one
recorded casualty along with multiple
injured Mine Workers wasn't enough to
her them from exploring what they had
accidentally stumbled upon venturing
into the cavern system pierced by the
drill those who first dared to set foot
down there were greeted by the sight of
strange crudely built stone structures
someone had been here before but how
nothing could survive this far below
ground nothing living nothing human at
least and that was true given that the
workers also came across something else
in their initial exploration human
remains of course this raised quite a
concern prompting the workers to try and
contact their superiors uncovering
bodies wasn't exactly uncommon for
anyone whose job it was to dig into the
ground so they at least had a protocol
in place for this kind of situation but
none of them were prepared for however
was the fiery Abomination that suddenly
emerged as they were trying to call for
help the creature was a nightmarish
blend of a humanoid shape with the head
of a dog and giant Wings much like a
bats covered in rough fur its body was
exuding an oily flammable substance
which it used to incinerate the
surviving Mine Workers in an instant by
the time that operatives of the SCP
Foundation arrived on scene in the town
of mirni within the sakha Republic the
creature was on a rampage buildings were
collapsing as the winged Beast set the
nearby area Ablaze troops on the ground
even once they were able to get the
monster in Range found that their
Conventional Weapons were useless it
cost the lives of 17 mobile task force
operatives all emulated down to a cinder
before a chopper was able to neutralize
the creature with the threat destroyed
and the town administered with amnestics
and fed a convincing cover story you'd
think that was case closed on a job well
done but the foundation discovered
within the nearby mersey mine something
that would completely change everything
they thought they knew deep underground
was a sinkhole leading to a spatial
anomaly below consisting of the system
of caverns that the Mine Workers had
inadvertently stumbled upon that was an
all that the foundation was about to
discover down there and what they came
across would soon become one of their
darkest Secrets
scp-3667 it wasn't long before the
foundation began encountering other
unusual creatures that seemingly
appeared in the vicinity of
scp-3667 however not all of them matched
the description of the original
batwinged dog-headed pyromaniacal
visitor officially dubbed as instances
of
scp-3667-1 these creatures range from
the aforementioned monstrosity to a
whole host of other strange descriptions
one was an abnormally thin humanoid
creature with reddish brown skin and a
head that was too big for its riry body
it possessed an ordinary human level of
intelligence and even spoke modern
Russian matching the common local
dialect in conversation this being tried
to offer well health or power in
exchange for a person's most valued
possessions however it seemed to possess
no anomalous abilities and would attempt
to renegotiate a new offer immediately
after a bargain was made then there were
the magistrates a group of 48 humanoids
with kyphotic curved spines all of them
wore Furs and a variety of skulls from
animals such as Elks deer and moose the
foundation were still none the wiser as
to the true origin of all these
different subspecies of creatures they
were obviously emanating from the
sinkhole and the foundation had been
making use of ntf chi-5 codenamed
Solomon seals to eliminate instances of
scp-3667-1 that appeared From Below
surface-to-air missile systems were even
installed nearby should any more flying
creatures appear but further exploration
into the sinkhole and the caverns below
would only yield further questions and
even more strange entities the
four-person unit attempt 5 Team 1 was
sent in to conduct preliminary
exploration into
scp-3667 to try and assess more
accurately the Threat Level posed by the
sinkhole and its bizarre residents
finding themselves in a large cave the
team followed the sounds of running
water to a wide stream the water a
yellowish gray in coloration they also
detected the sound of numerous Voices
All whispering in Russian but found it
too difficult to distinguish what they
were saying there were Remains Two of
some kind of structure that seemed to
indicate the existence of sentient life
within
scp-3667 there was a portion of a wall
even a hallway that led into a large
windowless circular room the floor of
this chamber featured an elaborate
Mosaic that seemed to have sustained
some damage but strangely it depicted
anomalous creatures including some that
looked like the first winged monster
that had appeared after splitting up
down various corridors two members of
Team One encountered a new entity from
within
scp-3667 this creature resembled a large
feline but had no eyes and was about 10
meters in height it referred to the MTF
operatives as Sinners and foolish
Mortals who should have stayed in their
cages despite being eyeless the creature
observed that the team did not possess
what it called The Mark of agriana and
remarks that they should not have been
there feeling threatened by the creature
ntf Kai 5 Team 1 was able to blow it up
with a grenade before being safely
retrieved by their fellow Foundation
Personnel exploration into
scp-3667 was then resumed by MTF Kai 5
teams 2 and 3 who were alarmed to hear
what sounded like a human scream coming
from somewhere within the caves while
they first assumed it was another 3667-1
creature someone suggested the
possibility that a civilian could have
stumbled onto the site of the mersey
mine before the foundation had arrived
and established a secure perimeter
around the sinkhole hearing the scream a
second time this time further away the
MTF agents decided to investigate just
in case an innocent person had been
dragged underground by one of the
creatures passing through a basin of the
same strange fluid that team one had
discovered the MTF teams could hear more
unsettling sounds coming from deep
within the caverns in particular a
repetitive scratching noise next they
discovered a large intricate wooden
structure a circle with one side that
appeared to be winched open inside they
could see rows of wooden spikes covered
in a dark liquid that everyone assumed
was blood hearing whimpers from their
supposed missing civilian the team's
Commander decided to call a retreat it
was then that the MTF realized there
were over 20 more wooden structures
nearby each was of a different shape and
size but all of them were covered in
rats that were staring at the foundation
operatives these various pieces of
wooden apparatuses seemed to resemble
torture devices and some of them had
bodies inside the MTF agents thought
they had discovered the grizzly faith of
their missing civilian little did they
know that things were far worse than
they first seemed the bodies and the
torture devices were still alive the
foundation soon realized there were
upwards of 12 000 people within
scp-3667 and immediately began efforts
to rescue as many as they could luckily
they had established a field base on
sight in the mine close enough to the
sinkhole that led into
scp-3667 however the unfortunate reality
was that saving all these trapped human
beings was no small undertaking and
space at their nearby base site 574 was
limited only 150 of the people were able
to be recovered and were transported to
site 574. those that were having been
found trying to escape from
scp-3667 or being eaten by the various
nightmarish creatures below but what
quickly became apparent was that these
people those safely recovered from
scp-3667 and those still trapped within
weren't exactly ordinary when team one
had discovered the strange yellow gray
stream in
scp-3667 they'd collected a sample of
the fluid for analysis examining this
sample revealed an anomalous molecular
structure that would actively bond with
organic matter and this same
unidentified molecule was present in the
bloodstream of the human beings found
beneath the sinkhole it seemed to have
bestowed each one of them with an
anomalous ability for a limited form of
regeneration their bodies could
withstand far more damage than an
average non-anomalous human the
foundation even experimented with
introducing the anomalous molecule into
the blood of other test subjects but it
didn't have the same regenerative effect
it was assumed that the Regeneration was
linked directly to some other factor and
the molecule from the fluid only acted
as a catalyst as such every person
recovered from the caverns was given the
collective designation of
scp-3667-2 now various subspecies of
strange creatures and a group of people
whose bodies could regenerate both
living in a system of caverns beneath
mirni sakha Republic not to mention and
all the wooden torture devices that were
being used on the
scp-3667-2s just what the hell was going
on here and what was it that made this
discovery one of the foundation's
darkest secrets well the answers to that
could be discovered in what they learned
next about the anomalous people they'd
recovered from the sinkhole as the
foundation continued its examination the
researchers at site 574 happened upon a
starting realization the
scp-3667-2 people were perfect physical
and genetic matches to former residents
of the nearby town of mirni in fact of
the over 12 000 total only 1 328 didn't
appear to correspond to any known person
from the area but then thousands of
others all had proof of their existence
that the foundation was able to recover
from the town's public records dates of
birth names former places of residence
family and next of kin along with dates
of death the
scp-3667-2 instances all claim to have
spent their entire lives underground
beneath the sinkhole where they were
tortured endlessly by nightmarish
creatures their bodies could regenerate
the external damage they received
meaning the torture would go on for days
months or even years at a time when
sampling bodies buried in local
cemeteries the foundation discovered
that these were in fact copies of
deceased residents but not everyone who
had lived and died in mernie only those
whose families had lived there for at
least two generations and who while they
were alive were suspected of committing
a crime but never convicted there was
one other unifying Factor too during
their lives these residents all had some
affiliation with a particular religious
group known as the light of five Heavens
Russian Orthodox Church to put it simply
scp-3667 was hell following a number of
other incursions involving
scp-3667-1 creature the foundation was
eventually able to open negotiations
with the entities in order to ensure the
continued stability of
scp-3667 the former director of site 574
nidai bokone was appointed as the
Director of hell and placed in charge of
overseeing the anomaly under her watch
the foundation would supposedly be
relocating the displaced
scp-3667-2s to safe classified locations
where they could be reintegrated into
society however in an email from the
director of Hal she proposed a solution
to the foundation's dwindling number of
d-class personnel I am happy to announce
that something has come up that changes
that I'll be sending each of you a
shipment of new d-class come next week
it isn't as many as you had hoped for
but rest assured these ones will
withstand most anything you throw at
them we've covered a lot here on this
channel and what you might have noticed
about the nature of our discoveries is
that knowledge is best broken down
before adjusted which is to say if you
are to learn how to assemble a computer
it may benefit you also to see one taken
apart when you do so you'll notice in
front of you not a computer at all but a
collection of individual Parts it's in
understanding these distinctive Parts in
isolation that helps us shape our
awareness of their marriage and how they
cooperate with one another to become
their Collective self sure this may be
good in practice but then tell me how do
we comprehend a whole that is composed
of Parts unwilling to isolate themselves
from the rest because let's face it not
all things let alone as CPS can be torn
apart for the convenience of our study
no matter the subject we seek to
understand it may choose to resist our
deconstruction by one way or another
landmarks like the temples of Malta and
the Pyramid of Jose are held together by
our respect monuments like the Statue of
Liberty are held together by copper the
family was held together by Charles
Manson but it's not always the
preservation of history or elements of
the periodic table or Psychopaths that
reject humans wishes to disassemble far
stronger than forces of nuts and bolts
are that of character and loyalty and
scp-2085 is welded together by exactly
that
scp-2085 is a militant Anarchist
organization consisting of six
cybernetically enhanced individuals A1
through A5 and B operating under the
name kuroi usagi shiden or more commonly
known as the black rabbit company
scp-2085-a subjects are five adult
female augmented humans designated
scp-2085-a-1 through
scp-2085-8-5 subjects are genetic
chimeras each with an estimated 6 to 10
different Gene donors they are fluent in
Japanese Mandarin China Chinese
Cantonese Korean Russian and English
with additional languages varying by
individual subjects display an array of
genetic and cybernetic enhancements
including genetic splices of felis
Caddis physiology that is having
cat-like ears tails and hair these tails
are prehensile and capable of holding
small objects so if you're accusing one
of them of stealing your pen don't just
go searching their pockets they also
have grip pads on hands and feet in case
they ever did decide to retire from
Anarchy and take up surfing their
impressive features don't stop there if
they haven't already put James Bond's
gadgets to shame yet just wait Daniel
Craig is about to look like Dora the
Explorer
scp-2085-a-1 through A-5 all have ocular
implants with thermal vision heads up
display and recording functionality also
noted are carbon nanoweave muscle fiber
augmentation reinforced endoskeleton and
brain computer interface with internal
hard drive the list goes on each Etc
more elaborate than the next yet what
stands out most about them is not a
weapon but an attitude these six members
although now held in isolation from one
another do not show any signs of
splitting up not even when under the
heavy pressure of the foundation's
interrogation agents spend their hours
looking for cracks to dig their fingers
into trying to get one to betray the
other and reveal sensitive information
but when asked to Spill the Beans
scp-2085 screws the lid on tighter they
remain as a whole resistant to our
deconstruction the agents get nowhere
with their investigation and with each
minute wasted it's another victory for
scp-2085 the hours go on and they keep
stacking up W's building momentum day
after day rowing stronger and stronger
as a unit as the foundation tries to
tear the group apart they they respond
with even greater resistance and this
style of resistance is unique to each
member imagine you are confronting
scp-2085-8-2 she is talkative and so you
think you might get somewhere you are
all ears but what
scp-2085-8-2 sees isn't ears but trots
and she is happy to feed you her slob
she talks and talks and you listen
closer and closer but all you are
getting is misinformation false names
inaccurate stories dates that don't add
up you focus and follow along only to
find yourself having run a marathon all
the way to a dead end now you are faced
with
scp-2085-8-5 who takes a different more
nonsensical approach you are happy to no
longer have to sit through inaccuracies
to decipher truths but now there are no
truths at all all that you are given are
absurdities she speaks in a way that
makes you scratch your your head once
saying for no apparent reason I take a
hammer and I break my legs I break them
for the better after so many scratches
you swear you've dug an inch into your
skin and so you move on to
scp-2085-a-4 hoping for better luck she
is straightforward with you that much
you like but she's hostile and doesn't
cooperate when you ask her her name she
raises her middle finger she tucks it
back in to create a fist and then that
fist punches the divider between you no
amount of reinforced glass could make
you feel safe at that moment cracks
spread it looks like a web spun by a
spider and you feel as small as one
thankfully a protective shutter is
lowered aerosol sedatives are pumped
into the containment unit she continues
to try to escape yelling profanities
even harsh for someone locked behind
bars your ears have taken a beating from
curse words nonsensical Rambles and
heaps of misinformation you want to
lower your head into a toilet bowl and
hear nothing but water yes that is where
these women have driven you your head to
the bottom of a toilet bowl you have put
in so many hours and yet you have
learned nothing new and if you can't
learn anything new you might have to
rely more on what you already know but
what do you know well you know this
their track record is quite impressive
verified operations include smuggling
theft assault vandalism kidnapping
extortion property damage possession of
fissile materials corporate sabotage
embezzlement identity theft fraud
copyright infringement piracy possession
transport and sale of anomalous items
and of course tax evasion yet when
grilled under the heat of Investigation
they do not reveal any details about the
nature of these operations you just know
that they happened all that is told is
that scp-2085 navigates in such a way as
to minimize the chance of of Civilian
casualties and maximize material and
morale damage to their target they are
proud of this it seems as if scp-2085
perceives themselves on the side of good
while their list of operations on paper
look like crimes they stand proudly
behind them pleading guilty with a grin
but behind every smile is more teeth
teeth that go beyond saying cheese teeth
hiding in the dark caves of a sealed
mouth and you are determined to play
dentist and find your way in but
scp-2085 doesn't say ah for just anyone
so how are you to understand a group
that resists our preferred methods of
learning how are you to properly assess
the pieces of a puzzle when the puzzle
is glued tightly together it starts at
the top before you can decipher the
motives of a Nation you'd be smart to
study their leader and if you want to
extrapolate the schemes of a football
team you'd interview the coach and to
truly know the moral of a television
show you'd be better off asking the
Creator than the actors all of this is
just to say if you are to ever
understand the complexities of scp-2085
it is necessary you begin with
scp-2085-b the person pulling the string
of the entire operation for all of these
years now you might be imagining a man
of many muscles someone able to fight a
bear with an arm tied behind his back
someone who kicks through saloon doors
tilts back his liquor and walks out with
a woman in each arm or a cat girl but
you'd be dead wrong
scp-2085-b also known as wizard does not
look like an imposing lead at first
glance or even at the hundredth glance
he is generally in very poor health and
his face shows it he suffers from a
variety of illnesses most notably a
vitamin D deficiency acute radiation
syndrome and as unmanageable scarring
from severe and repeated skin ulceration
he doesn't wear a cape and glamorous
spandex often found hanging in
superhero's closets but instead he wears
an advanced crew escape suit accompanied
by a cheap bathrobe and flimsy red felt
wizard's hat he looks with no elegant
way of putting it like a dork a goofball
a doofus
you get the point furthermore he is an
adult male human with certain cybernetic
and genetic enhancements he has an
adaptation of the gastrointestinal tract
to allow for an all-liquid diet within
his suit an esophageal input port and
waste output Port are integrated it is
equipped with modifications to regulate
sweat reduce abrasion damage from
extended usage and Aid in skin
regeneration his genetic enhancements
include the replacement of 11 previously
missing digits on hands and feet and
also has an internal drug
typically used for painkillers because
as we are about to learn
scp-2085-b is most often on the wrong
end of pain notice these modifications
are not those you would find in a
science fiction novel but more likely
behind the trench coat of a suspicious
man in a dark alley and we all know
nothing good is ever concealed behind a
trench coat but have you ever wondered
if that truth also extends to Rogues
because when we pull open
scp-2085s what we find is truly
terrifying
scp-2085-1
scp-2085-1 is a fibrous mass of
self-replicating carbon nanomaterials
within
scp-2085-b's chest cavity with growths
protruding into the liver pancreas
gallbladder spinal cord and left lung
the growth of the scp-2085-1 and its
consumption of
scp-2085-b's body tissues has been
impeded through the addition of various
containment implants used to sever
communication between growth sections
and control nodes and counter the
replication process
scp-2085-1's rate of replication without
the influence of these containment
implants is unknown
scp-2085-1's periods of activity occur
on average once every three months the
process lasts for up to 15 minutes and
causes
scp-2085-b intense pain imagine a heart
attack imagine Mike Tyson using your
sternum like a punching bag imagine a
cactus strapped to your front this is
the pain and torture
scp-2085 wears daily there is no S logo
printed on his chest like Superman no
symmetrically slick symbol like Batman
instead just cancerous growth Kryptonite
worn like a tie the knot never to be
loosened but to scp-2085-b
this anomaly is not just a number to be
studied but more so a being to be
understood it is more personal than a
medical condition it is something that
he wakes up with each and every day he
calls it red at first the foundation saw
scp-2085's close connection with red to
be childish and silly as if a small boy
who names his freckles out of boredom
and loneliness but as you are about to
see how they met was more memorable than
first finding a freckle in the mirror a
meteor struck down and
scp-2085-b was the only person at the
scene red was inside as wizard
approached the meteor red leapt onto him
and buried a home into his chest cavity
far from a freckle on the skin red is a
cancer it grows and grows leeching to
what it can it can't be removed with
surgery it can't be covered by a
Band-Aid it has no empathy or Mercy it
leeches on one and eats away at its host
but it's more than pain that it causes
falling off a swing set and bursting
open your leg hurts sure but at least
both you and your injury are on the same
team Cuts try to heal when left alone
injuries make effort to find homeostasis
but red is a different breed it hates us
in a way that injuries are incapable of
doing it has a deep disdain for Humanity
it tears wizard down reveling in his
degradation its sole purpose is to eat
him whole wizard can only take this
personally as he doesn't just feel the
universally understood sensation of pain
but also the unique passion of its
purpose
scp-2085-b's adventures with red seem to
be where our Story begins and what
ultimately keeps it moving in fact it
was while
scp-2085-b was running around trying to
fix his chest with implants when he
eventually met who we refer to as
scp-2085-a-1 through 8-5 he was at the
clinic to get some new parts and when he
was going through the installation
process there was an explosion one of
the five girls barged out of a building
guns blazing he started running
alongside them with his chest half open
the woman embraced him immediately and
reciprocated knowing nothing of the
situation he instinctively knew to take
their side there were bullets coming
from both directions but he intuitively
understood which side was good and which
side was bad a distinction scp-2085
believes the world needs help clarifying
but it is hard to see a reason for a war
when our eyes are focused on the
casualties beliefs are less clear when
tucked behind bullets the sounds of
gunfire muffled their message morality
while a complex subject
scp-2085 believes is simplified by the
masses events are deemed good or bad
based on the term used for them in a
court of law when we see the words
smuggling theft assault vandalism
corporate sabotage embezzlement identity
theft fraud copyright infringement
piracy and of course tax evasion it is
our impulse to label those as morally
bad but scp-2085 desperately wants you
to look Beyond The Language they want
the words to dissipate off the paper
letter by letter until all you have is a
blank page now look at the pencil and
the hand that holds it watch how it
moves that is what matters whether it
draws weapons or mermaids is irrelevant
both can be used for good both can be
used for evil intent is everything and
scp-2085 intends on making the world a
better place or so they like to claim
but maybe there is more to it after a
scp-2085-b and the five women escape the
gunfire they went on to steal a boat and
hightail it out of Japan they spent
their nights out there on the ocean
stargazing and stuffing themselves with
instant Ramen and cheap beer and
surprisingly between all the crazy
Adventures as
cp2085-b had been on this is what
Wizards spoke about most the time spent
on the boat out at sea for the first
time in ages he was finally somewhere
where he was happy it was this moment
that actually meant the most to him it
wasn't the children they apparently
saved from imperialism it wasn't the
wealth they apparently redistributed to
the poor it wasn't any good deed at all
it was the selfish almost shallow
sensation of being happy on a boat this
singular moment meant so much to
scp-2085-b he reflected on it as if it
were a wedding day or a memorable
vacation which makes you wonder
scp-2085 has been investigated and
interrogated and all that they preach is
that they are doing the world a favor
with their Antics their tails are
captivating sure but is it actually
storytelling or is it just virtue
signaling there is an emotional depth to
scp-2085 Unique to any other militant
Anarchist group while they are
genetically designed to most efficiently
complete missions they're not all robots
fixed on the high of task completion
each and every one of them wants more
they want to grow they want a group not
just to have the numbers to overthrow a
government but to have the numbers to
fill a room or boat with companionship
when they refuse to cooperate with you
and leak information about their
operation maybe what you are witnessing
isn't the strength of their loyalty but
also the weakness of their codependence
and so you decide this is the new angle
you're going to take with your
interrogation you enter the room with a
new Focus you feel like an earthquake
eager to make cracks in their core you
isolate
scp-2085-a-4 you are met expectantly
with hostility you fight back with
psychology you cross your legs and put
on your glasses as if to say let's talk
about that anger where does it stem from
she strengthens her emotional guard but
you keep prying you say that it sounds
like she is lonely you say it sounds
like her loyalty doesn't come from good
character but rather insecurity and
self-doubt you ask her if completing
missions with her crew was actually a
way to improve the world or was it just
an elaborate way to build a close friend
group bound together by Common goals did
New Missions Sprout from necessity or
were they fabricated by fears of being
alone with nothing to do or end of
operation high fives to celebrate good
overcoming evil or were they just
excuses to feel the touch of another
human skin to skin you stop there and
let's silence do the rest
scp-2085-8-4 sits with her thoughts she
is ready to break and find she does she
says she's willing to provide video logs
of the group's former operations she's
ready to cooperate she's ready to
abandon loyalty to groupthink and focus
instead on self-improvement in exchange
she kindly asks that she be reciprocated
and that the sanction placed on her be
lifted you come to an agreement and with
that you feel like your work is done but
is it you're feeling cocky and
accomplished you forward the video logs
to an isolated Network for d-class
personnel to review and you sit back and
enjoy a celebratory drink you have
infiltrated and broken the mind of a
genetically modified radical design for
Anarchy you give yourself a pat on the
back and you're feeling so great that
the pat might even turn into a massage
but before you can indulge in that deep
tissue level of self-admiration the
phone rings can it be a call from the
President telling you that you're the
greatest investigator of all time can it
be that they need you to pose in front
of a world-renowned artist so they can
erect a statue of you in the center of
town square but the Panic on the other
side of the phone halts your Daydream
your stomach drops as if a sudden
plummet from a perfectly vertical roller
coaster you have fallen into a trap the
video log at the center of your
negotiation was not all it was promised
to be the file titled backup.avi
consisted of a two hour long video of a
feces filled toilet presumably recorded
from
scp-2085-a's point of view accompanied
by an audio Loop of the folk song
korobaniki as performed by the Red Army
Choir its absurdity feels like an art
project like a short film you are
assigned to watch in a community college
class but instead of putting you to
sleep it does a whole lot more the
contained audio visual Cognito Hazard
induced anaphylaxis and exudative
diarrhea in the observing d-class
subject the d-class subject died four
minutes after initial access of the file
from blood loss and oxygen deprivation
scp-2085-a-4 sits in containment
laughing while you sit there on your
couch dethroned back where you started
having thought you tore scp-2085 apart
with your mind only to learn that your
efforts only reinforced it with more
glue now go check out scp-247 a harmless
kitten and scp-577 bullet cat for more
scps that'll melt or claw out a cab
lover's heart